Film Courage: Jeff, why do you teach
writing? Jeff Kitchen, Dramatist / Author /
Founder / Consultant: I've been fascinated with
the technique of writing ever since I got into it
well really it started in prep school when I had
three good English teachers in a row and I always
responded in a course if I liked the teacher,
if I didn't like the teacher I wouldn't perform
if I did I would go for it and we had these
one teacher was a Scottish fellow who spent three
months reading Macbeth to us and translated it all
and translated the ambient world of Shakespeare to
help make more sense of it and he would read a few
lines of Macbeth and then talk for 45 minutes
about what was going on and end up at the end
of that talk about how in the old west the idea
that you could pull out your revolver and shoot
somebody's gun out of their hand he said that's
so unrealistic because you could put one of those
pistols in a vice and never hit the same spot
twice so that would be like just the level of
you know interesting material that i was being
exposed to and i learned how to write there write
essays and stuff like that so that when i ran
into a fellow in vermont who was a playwright
and he offered to teach a friend of mine
playwriting i asked if i could jump in on that
he taught us the basics of aristotle and
he gave us these two books to read and
i sat down and read them for three years
uh that's pretty much all i did trying to
at first because i was a painter before that so i
came into playwriting knowing nothing and knowing
that i knew nothing so it makes it easier to
learn if you don't already think you know it
and this fellow william thompson price was he was
a script doctor two broadway producers around 1910
um he helped revise every play that this uh
producer david belasco produced on broadway he's
quite famous and so many people were coming to him
asking for help with their scripts and with the
tools he created for playwriting technique that
he started the first school of playwriting ever
and uh he had 28 students 24
of them had hits on broadway
and he wrote this one book in 1908 which
is the one i sat down and started reading
at first i couldn't understand it it was
really dense and complex but i kept working
my way through it and he kept checking in as a
teacher saying you have to understand what i just
explained otherwise you should just forget the
whole thing because this is key so and i would i
would stop and he'd go stop and think about it and
see if you understand it and at first i was like
i really don't understand it at all so i go back
and reread it and i still didn't understand it
because it was it's like when einstein said when
he first started studying uh theoretical physics
the stuff that he specialized in he was stupefied
by it for the first two years it was so complex
that he was stupefied by it this material is
obviously you know way easier than that but the
degree of complexity was still a lot for me and
so i read price's book and then his students book
and then i read price's book again on his students
book again and after a while i got to where i was
understanding what they were talking about
but felt like i still couldn't use it
and so when i started teaching people i did
hands-on training i did small groups maximum six
people each person had to bring their own story
that they were working on so i could get them
actually using the tool instead of them just
listening to me talk about it because i understood
that you could get to a place where you understand
it and still not be able to actually use it so
that's why i would work hands-on with each person
in the group and just the science of it and the
art of it is has always been fascinating and it's
just something that people have responded well
to the know-how that i was giving them and it
was stimulating and and interesting so i've just
remained fascinated by it have you ever thought
back to with those three teachers had they been
teachers that maybe you didn't necessarily want to
perform for or impress or have like your work the
trajectory of what your life would have been yeah
no i wouldn't have been fascinated with writing
i don't think it ever would have come up i mean
i love to read and i love movies and plays and
great novels and that's kind of thing but as
a as something that i felt strongly compelled
to dive into and gain a mastery of i don't know
if it would have been there how important is it
for you to have students feel similar maybe you
can disagree on many things but at least they
want to do well for you how how important
is that and how does one establish that
i'm not entirely sure partly because by the time
they seek out someone like me they already have
some kind of passion for the material
now i may awaken in them a deeper passion
as they see that they could
as they see that there's more perhaps than
they thought there was to learn and that
because the way in which i teach is is is
scientific in its own way because each of
the tools has certain distinctions like to
use the tool properly you have to be able
to make certain distinctions for instance like
in dilemma consists of two equally unacceptable
alternatives so there's real distinctions
in that so it's two on two painful choices
and for for it to be a real dilemma
they have to be equally unacceptable
because if you you could have two unacceptable
choices where do you want to get burned by a match
or do you want to jump in the lava those are both
unacceptable but they're nowhere near equal but
if you have to choose between you know sacrificing
your husband or your son to like you know a slave
owner who's going to take one or the other you
that's that when they're equal and of magnitude
then it really paralyzes the protagonist and
renders the material riveting to the audience
so the distinctions are key for using the
tools properly and so once a student sees that
there's a real specificity to the use
of these tools and if you use them
properly and fully you can get
tremendous power especially out of
a story that has promised but has not been
performing for them so that the ability to
it's kind of like being a martial
arts teacher from one point of view
where somebody may have some fighting skills but
you're able to go look you keep your elbow up
and they can you know there's certain technical
things that you can show them that you can turn
them into a considerably better fighter pretty
quickly if they already have some basic skills
by no by key distinctions and observation and
just know-how so that it's you know it's a uh
it's a process of giving students genuine know-how
and once they see that
they really could master this stuff if they
apply themselves and they've seen their
script improve a lot from working hands-on
with me in the class that that can really
give them a fire in the belly because whereas
before they just wanted to write stories now they
understand the distinction between a storyteller
and a dramatist and that if you're going to
turn us if you're going to adapt a story for a
theatrical presentation whether that's a film tv
show theater that it has to be the story has to be
stage worthy it has to be able to be performed by
an actor in such a way that it grips the audience
so there's a lot of specificity to making a
theatrical presentation of a story work in
such a way that it really grips an audience
and once they get a handle on this is
considerably different than what i thought
it was and that's only true for some people some
people come in with a lot of knowledge already
and i'm just showing them a few more tools but
there but the tools are powerful enough that they
can see that if they really apply themselves and
learn to use them fully and properly that they'll
their scripts will tend to work and so
that can really amplify somebody's passion
tell us about your cognitive apprenticeship
the cognitive apprenticeship is
quite fascinating it was something that
i discovered just as i was beginning to
um create this particular training program i had
thought about it for a good couple years because
i always taught in small hands-on groups and i
didn't see how to teach bigger groups because
the material is complex and sophisticated enough
that in my experience unless i got you doing it
on your script that it was abstract enough so
that even if you listen to an explanation of it
then when you go home and try to do
it on your own partially formed script
you generally don't have enough
know-how and experience and just
general knowledge and working know-how to
to use it across a broad spectrum of ideas
so i spent a couple years trying to figure out how
to teach larger groups and in the process of that
i also studied the science of how people learn
and that has grown and changed tremendously in
the last 100 years and hugely in the last 50 years
they've figured out so much about the science of
how people learn to the point where they even have
people in an mri and they're doing experiments on
them teaching them things and seeing which
parts of their brain light up and all that
so that they understand much more completely
how people learn they've even figured out
that in the process of acquiring an expert
skill that the brain creates a neural network
specifically for the acquisition and
retention of that particular skill
and if you're and the more that you practice
it with complete attention complete attention
and strong intention that this neural network you
can picture it like a dirt road which connects
two two sections of the brain very close together
and the signal travels from one to the other
and the more you diligently practice like
if you're learning to be a baseball pitcher
and you practice over and over and really
stay focused with a good coach that that
neural network gets enhanced it literally
grows and changes and what they found is that
the brain does what's called myelination
it's a it's a fatty coating that insulates
that neural network from outside chatter so it
gets more focused and that myelination continues
so that neural network literally gets broader
and faster and so it turns into an information
superhighway where it used to be a dirt road and
so the people that have substantial expert skills
it's built into their brain and it will never go
away it does not go away so like for instance when
i was a kid i did a lot of games um like skittle
bowl which is a a thing on a ball and a chain
and you send it around and it comes in and you're
bowling and i did that you know thousands of times
and i got quite good with the motion so that there
was one game where it's two steel rods connected
at one end and there's a steel ball and you have
to squeeze the rods together and that forces the
ball to go slightly uphill and it's really hard to
master because the ball keeps falling through it's
a touch where you have to you're letting it roll
downhill slightly and squeezing them together so
it keeps going up and let it and you gradually
work it up and i got really good at that when i
was like 12 or something i did it constantly and
i saw one in somebody's house a couple years ago
i went up to i was like i used to be able to do
this and i tried it and on the very first try
i did it perfectly this is like really really
hard to do and so it shows you like that once
it's really seated in your brain at that level
that it's permanent in the process of studying
this fascinating material about the science
of learning and and looking at how i taught
because i didn't want to teach the same way i did
i didn't find it effective enough to do a 30 hour
intensive which is very much like fire hose
teaching where i'm just hammering you with
a complex array of information that's not easy
to retain and i always felt dissatisfied like i
could do more i could do better they could
they could come away from my training with
very substantial skills instead of some sense of
it and really excited about it and so i pulled
a lot of interesting stuff together and
teaching techniques and then a week before uh
lockdown hit i sat down and started building
this particular training program full-time
and then covet hit and i had even more time
because i wasn't driving the kids around and that
kind of stuff so i really focused and i found this
essay one of the one of the books on the science
of learning talked about these people who did some
interesting stuff with the science of learning i
looked them up and found an essay they had written
about cognitive apprenticeship which is which is
built upon a standard apprenticeship which is how
people learn best you know working with a master
to become a shoemaker barrel maker that kind of
thing that's been around for thousands of years
and so all of that is still there
it's still very much an apprenticeship
but the cognitive apprenticeship has to do
with the cognitive skills that accompany some
sorts of training processes like for instance
if you're apprenticing to a lawyer say they
wouldn't call it apprenticeship these days but
you're still studying right with people in the
law sure there's lots of stuff of like how
you do things and what you say in court and
and the technicalities of the law but so much of
it is cognitive facility of how you think so the
process of how you think from one point of view
is everything in in a in a skill set like that
so it was fascinating in that as i'm trying to as
i'm sitting down to create this training program
and it's going to be a two-year training program
for writers uh in the craft of the
dramatist that i found this 30-page essay
and as i'm reading it i'm going like this is like
to the t exactly what i'm doing so it was like
finding you know a high performing rocket fuel
right when you're building a rocket like you
didn't know you even needed it and then somebody
shows up with this stuff and it changes everything
so i spent a month reading these 30 page essay
over and over again read it once read it once
yellow highlight then went over that and pink
highlight and then worked with that and typed
up all the highlighted things and sorted them for
prioritization and categorization and put them on
three by five cards and like okay i need to put
this into this part of training someone in the
craft or the dramatist and it really consolidated
and amplified so much of what i was doing
and you know the the craft of the dramatist is so
much it's it's more a way of thinking than a set
of rules it's the habits of mind of a trained
dramatist is what i'm training people in and
that's what it's always been but these people were
talking about exactly that the habits of mind that
go along with teaching something sophisticated
to people so it was a fully developed science
that through a couple years of hard work i
hit upon just at the right moment and i really
built that into the course in every
way possible so that i was constantly
using what i had learned about the science
of how people learn the science of cognitive
apprenticeship and the cu and the science
of training for expertise um i was always
using that to change how i
teach to the point where i would
finish one lesson and be getting ready to start
another whole tool and one of the things they talk
about um i'm not sure if it was in cognitive
apprenticeship or in the science of expertise
the science of expertise is quite fascinating this
fellow named anders ericsson created it in 1983 it
was not a science before that he started visiting
these training facilities around the world that
turned out disproportionately large numbers of
high-level ballerinas chess players olympic ski
champions all these highly specialized
skills and some people were turning out
substantial experts more than anybody
else so he went and visited them and
hung out with them and studied what they
were doing and took all the stuff that
he learned from these coaches and studied it
scientifically and then took it even further
and he died this summer but his last book
called peak really synthesized it all really
substantially and that's considered the high water
mark in the war in the world of training expertise
this guy invented the science changed the whole
thing and um then the last book is the is the is
the high watermark and that's required reading
in my course it's course material for the class
so one of the things they talk about either in the
science of learning or peak in in the science of
expertise is that they've found that the harder
it is to learn something the better you retain it
so what i did so these talk about changing gears
pulling the rug out from under the students
flipping things on their head making them work
for it all these ways to make it to make them
more independent and aggressive
and proactive as learners
means that it sticks much better in them
because you want permanent substantial know-how
not mere knowledge if you know stuff about
things that doesn't mean you can actually
do it at a professional level just because you
have knowledge about it so uh as like i finished
one course and i was getting ready to one lesson
and i was changing to another whole topic and
i was like okay so how can i utilize what
i've learned best now that i'm starting
a whole new area and one of the things
they found that's quite fascinating is
that if you give if you make people tackle
a problem before they've been trained in it
that it makes them better students better thinkers
for instance in math a teacher would give you a
problem that you're not equipped to solve yet
and that you haven't been trained in yet and
the teacher would say look i'm not trying to get
you to solve it i just want you to wrestle with it
take a whack at it see what you can do and then
when the teacher explains the tool later on and
the teacher is showing one complex part of that
equation and the teacher says it so here's the
trick for how you do this particular thing instead
of the students being there like i hate this stuff
they're like oh that's how you do that wow look
at that they're invested in it they've already
done part of the work and they're like they're
you know they're aggressive independent thinkers
really trying to learn it rather than bored
kids wishing they were out playing frisbee or
whatever so it's a it's a way to it's a specific
methodology of teaching that has proven to work
and so i brought that in as much as i could
into training in the craft or the dramatist
so that i will give my students a complex idea
that i haven't trained them in yet and ask them
to just think it through and it's an exercise
called think it through just think about it for
15 minutes and then write for five minutes and
i'm not expecting you to get it right some of
you know more than others and you will some of
you don't know anything but take a whack at it
like what's the difference between a storyteller
and a dramatist there's real distinctions and
someone with more experience would understand that
someone who doesn't might have trouble with it but
they can wrestle with it and they can think about
it and whatever thinking they do adds up and it
informs their learning process and it
turns them into more sophisticated students
uh for instance one of the things in my class
is that not only do i not answer i only really
teach one thing the craft of the dramatist and
i don't answer any questions about anything
else because i need i want the focus and i
don't want questions that are unrelated and
i don't answer stupid questions where i'll say
no you go think about that some more you're just
tossing out a dumb question like you see that a
lot on like facebook writer groups where people
post these really dumb questions like should my
protagonist's girlfriend have red hair it's like
first of all who cares but why are you asking us
that's my main reaction is you can't figure that
out on your own it's like you know you're a writer
get some grit dig in and figure it out and so
that all factors into the cognitive apprenticeship
because i'm teaching them how to think
and how to process and how to tackle
things at a professional level
and so that by the time they've
gone through the program they will
be much more aggressive independent thinkers
and they also learn to evaluate their own ideas
you have to be able to generate ideas and
you also have to be able to evaluate them
because you can make up stuff all day long but
if half of it's no good and you can't tell the
difference it doesn't do anybody any good
you're not going to sell it you know it's
it's not working so one of the things i do is
that in the forum with the groups of students
i might give them an assignment if we're all
working on the same script i'd say okay we
got to figure out a way that she can sneak
the gun into this room before the meeting
and it has to be good it can't
be some stupid idea so let's
your assignment is to come up with 10 different
ways she could sneak the gun into the room
and then when they before they post it post their
answer on the forum that everybody can see i say
then look at your ideas and bubble sort
them let the best ones bubble to the top
so your top three are good and then post them
and then everybody look at everybody else's
and take take the best of all those and bubble
sort those into the best so that what you bring
me is the top 30 out of what maybe hundreds or
more ideas and then i'm making them do the work
so that they're gaining skill at creating
evaluating collaborating which is also very
important in the entertainment industry and
they can work as a team to present me with
ideas that are everywhere from very good
to incredibly good to off the charts good
and some of them might be so good that we're
like wow that's a whole screenplay on itself
let's park that over here and make that
into something so that it's a it's a way of
just making them into
professional storytellers on top of seasoned
versatile dramatists because you gotta have both
uh great storytelling without craft as a dramatist
it still won't be stage worthy it won't work as a
performance piece and that actors can act and
will grip an audience and mere structure isn't
worth very much either well-structured crap
is still crap it just runs like a swiss watch
so you really got to have both and so the
cognitive apprenticeship is apprenticeship in
the craft of the dramatist how to make a story
work dramatically and the craft of storytelling
and the whole thought process thought
processes that go into all of that
is crucial because how you
think is how you mold your story
and how you dramatize it and just your general
attack as a storyteller so you're coming up with
things that are fresh and things that aren't
you know just cliche and easy to come up with
you know so it's about challenging
them and making them work for it
and really bringing up their level of expertise
and their cognitive facilities and then there's
one more layer in cognitive apprenticeship which
is that you not only need the actual hard skill
but you also need the cognitive facility
the subtle thinking habits and often
hidden thinking habits that the expert has
some of which the expert doesn't even know
they're doing so by spending time with them you
gradually see how they tackle a problem even if
they're not aware of all of it because they
may have forgotten a bunch of it 20 years ago
or sort of invented it subconsciously or just
have good habits because of all their training
and so in addition to the hard skill and the
cognitive facility there's also what's called
metacognition which is the ability to evaluate
your own cognitive process to get above your own
professional thinking process and go you know
i think i was going about this all wrong like
what i was doing was correct but i think i'm
like in the wrong ballpark so the ability to
look at your thinking and go god you know i think
i was completely wrong about that whole part of it
and then you like you may invent a whole new way
to do it or just change gears or you know maybe
you had a team of 10 people working on a project
for you and you realize that they didn't need
one person doing it for two days could do what
they were trying to do 10 people in two weeks
but the other part of the problem you should have
had 30 people on for the last three months because
you noticed how much more significant
this one piece of the puzzle was
when you stepped back and looked at your own
cognitive process so it's the it's the ability to
um master your own mastery in a certain
way and that's a that's a key component of
cognitive apprenticeship as well but it's a
full it's a full bunch of skill sets and it
really lends itself well to training
people on the craft of script writing
never let anyone tell you that a story's
already been told yeah that's a fun one um
it goes back to
being a bull in a china shop as a writer that
your attack as a storyteller is so
key to succeeding as a writer um
lazy writing limp writing it's it's often so
forgettable and the key word in the entertainment
industry is outrageousness people go to the
movies or watch a tv show or go to the theater
to see something extraordinary something
different something energizing something
fun or exciting or meaningful or cathartic so
it has to do with
a rebellious streak where
you know many people have heard the saying there's
nothing new under the sun every story's been told
there's only seven basic stories
or three basic stories or whatever
and part of me completely understands that
and part of me that just pisses me off
it's like you know you can't tell me
that i can't come up with something
that's that you've never seen that will it just
it's like waving a red flag in front of a bull it
it just makes me mad and it it brings out
the attack in me and the desire to shatter
people's expectations and blow people's minds
and take them where they've never been and
just violate their expectations
violate my own storytelling rut
you know it's you know think of a movie like
being john malkovich you know it's like so off
the beaten track and i'm sure there was somebody
telling the writer oh you shouldn't do
that that's not how stories go it's like
it's just weak and it's it's such a lack
of adventure and a lack of courage and and
just you know one of my favorite
terms is attack as a storyteller
how much attack do you bring to the table what
what are the ways that you can dazzle an audience
take them on a ride that they've never been on
and if you accept the idea that you can't
possibly come up with something that
nobody's ever seen then
it kind of takes the wind out of your
sails in a certain way it says you're
you're not all that creative you can't
come up with something it's like i
i refuse to play that way i go the other
end of the spectrum i always want to
know what are the extremes in any
story idea just to see what they are
you often you know you'll find yourself if you're
trying to solve a story problem where you got to
figure out a specific thing in a story where
there's kind of a normal set of possibilities
and then there's unusual possibilities
and then there's extreme possibilities
and like for instance the coen brothers
say that if somebody can figure out
our next move if they had a week to figure
it out and they can figure it out in a week
we're not going to use it they go way above
and beyond shaking up your expectations
violating your expectations if you're
trying to solve a story problem and you have
a selection of possibilities for ways you could
get out of that situation or whatever one of the
things i've found is really fun is is to not only
look at the extremes because it gets you out of
the stock choices in the ordinary but what i also
want to know just out of pure curiosity is what's
the single craziest possibility in the whole
universe for that particular choice what it's like
wildly crazy and usually it won't work at all but
sometimes you'd be like well that's interesting
if i backed it down a few notches it could start
to fit into my arena and it's really fresh and
different and takes the story in a different
direction and shakes up the character and
every once in a while that single craziest idea
works brilliantly in a completely unexpected way
i've had that happen to me where i said well
what's the single craziest idea and it would be
like well it would be that and be like whoa
i never would have thought of that and i'm
using that it's great so it's that's part of
attack as a storyteller just going for it and
not just stretching the envelope envelope but
you know obliterating it and just having fun you
know it's writing's fun but you're using analogies
similar to war and or combat in some way is is
going facing the the page every day like combat
it's a good question because
it depends in many ways on
who you are because if you are
someone with the martial arts skills of
bruce lee say then you get into the ring
with pretty much any fighter
you can figure something out
so it's so it's not like god i don't know what i'm
gonna do i'm staring at the blank page it's like
no i can i can make this work you know this guy
weighs 600 pounds so i got to figure something out
but you know bruce lee is going to
bring a lot of stuff to the table
so the more skill you have as a storyteller
and as a scriptwriter as a dramatist
the less intimidated you are by a normal
array of writing challenges now you really
want to get in over your head if it's all
too easy then you're not doing your job right
so like if i'm starting in on a script and it
starts to get complex and deep part of my brain
goes uh-oh we're getting in over our my head
here and the other part of my brain goes yeah
that's that's good that's where you want to be
and they say that writers are like show horses
they're not happy unless they're trying to
jump over something that could kill them
and i was thinking about that last night
and i found an actually much better analogy
is that writers are like extreme rock climbers
or something they're not happy climbing something
unless it could well kill them if it's too
less of a challenge they're like they're
bored that's they get their adrenaline from
the fact that nobody's ever climbed this cliff
and they're doing with no ropes and they're
hanging by you know like two fingers on a piece
of rock that big and they're like this is fun this
is life and they don't want to do anything else
they even found that the like the combat
nurses and medics who came back from vietnam
couldn't go back to a normal job it was too i
can't sit in a corner and file papers so they
ended up as like emergency room physicians and
you know frontline cops so like they had to be in
in the deep stuff to because it was it didn't
cut it anymore for them so the more craft
you bring to the table the less intimidated
you are by the material but you also want to be
in over your head they said that bob marley who
grew up on the water when they got bored he and
his brother would swim out to sea as far as they
could until they were completely exhausted and
then they'd try to make it back to shore that was
their idea of like a fun afternoon so it's kind of
like that it's like the material should challenge
you but you should also be throwing hand grenades
into your own story ideas to make your job harder
to challenge yourself so that like a rock climber
is like i'm not going to take that safe route i'm
going to do this dangerous route over here that
nobody's ever done before and it may well kill me
but i can't live without that level of challenge
so i'm not sure if that answered your question
exactly i think it does i think that basically
you're saying you need to be stimulated
but not bored and it can't be too easy
and so it's kind of like playing chess a hobbyist
playing chess with an expert versus a hobbyist
playing chess with another hobbyist right and that
the the more substantial your craft as a writer
the less it seems like how can i possibly
do this you know it's a job it's a story and
of course it's challenging and it's hard but
like bruce lee facing whatever opponent he's like
i may get my ass kicked but i know
what i'm doing and i can take this on
you know i'm not it's not like what am i going
to do what am i going to do it's like no i
know exactly what i'm going to do i just have to
figure out how to do it for this particular thing
can you define a dramatist versus a storyteller
sure a storyteller is just making up a story and
any kind of story whether you're making up
a little five-minute story for your kid to
go to sleep with or you're coming up with uh
lord of the rings or game of thrones yeah like
high-end complex storytelling that's huge and to
succeed as a scriptwriter you need storytelling
skills as big as you can get them the craft
of the dramatist is connected to storytelling
but distinct from it also because the craft of the
dramatist is how you dramatize a story to adapt it
for theatrical presentation so it has you have
to make your story so that actors can perform it
on film on tv on stage and that it grips the
audience so the audience is on the edge of their
seat wondering what comes next you're making the
material compelling and conformable performable so
the craft of the dramatist is ancient
the first person who really chimed in
on it that we know of was aristotle
he was not a playwright but each year
athens had a religious theater festival in which a
topic was assigned to the playwrights of athens so
aristotle would over a couple day period
see 25 different versions of euripides not
you that was a playwright of um well what's i'm
blanking on the name of the play um oedipus so
uh he was able to compare and contrast all these
different playwrights takes on the edible myth
and he found that some of them put the audience to
sleep and some of them really gripped the audience
and he's like well what is it about those dramas
that grip an audience is there anything common
among them and he found that they tended to have
a good strong dilemma building to a crisis forcing
decision action in the face of crisis with with
a resolution of the dilemma by the protagonist
and uh a denum the upshot the epilogue
these were things that aristotle noticed
tended to be common to those dramas that
gripped an audience and then throughout
the years there were french classicists who
did amazing work and um shakespeare and
and you know just playwrights in general
and the science has continued to evolve um
there was a a new set of tools were created
by this um script this broadway script dr
william thompson price uh that he put out
in his book 1908 and he was teaching to
his students and he created these tools
because he found that
most of the scripts that were submitted
for broadway productions that he was
working with the broadway producers on missed
the mark in some way a high degree of them
and that's still true today that 90 to 95 of
all scripts submitted are do not work at all
they're horrible rejected unreadable and the
studio readers say don't kid yourself it's 98
so what price did was he said these people
are not landing in the ballpark very often and
they're not stupid and they're good storytellers
they don't have enough craft as a dramatist
and price was trained as a lawyer that was his
first profession and being trained in the logic
of argumentation the ability to state a complete
court case as a and b therefore c and that is a
rigorous process and if you present the logic of a
court case in the proper way then it's irrefutable
you prove your case by a and b therefore c and
your client wins so he said there ought to be a
way to state the complete action of a script with
that level of simplicity and clarity and he by by
adapting the proposition of logic to drama he
created this tool because a proposition is a
and b therefore c you're proposing that this
is true and this is true therefore this is true
and he worked on it for a long time he never
ceased to be dissatisfied with it but he
created it and advanced it and was able to
help their students his students plays work
24 of his 28 students had hits on broadway um but
he was constantly trying to synthesize it better
but it definitely worked and
there was another playwriting teacher
who i found out later was who taught
price's technique of the proposition
after price died in 1920 uh prices student
wrote a book in 1928 which is what those two
books i read for three years and then this other
playwriting teacher wrote a book in 1950 but he'd
been teaching crisis proposition and he advanced
it even further and what this teacher said was um
i'm trying to remember the exact wording can i
read it to you from my book it's i have it right
here if that's helpful oh you do okay i know
it by memory but i'm not dredging up all of it
this is my book writing a great movie uh
key tools for successful screenwriting
so let me read you actually a quote by
price about the proposition he's writing in
1912. one main proposition is the essence of unity
it is unity and unity can be procured in no other
way it is impossible that two main ideas exist in
the same play the house will be divided against
itself two bodies cannot occupy the same space
at the same time the play itself that which is
developed from the one idea is about many things
but the discerning eye of the author should
penetrate to the heart of things true dramatic
instinct which is largely the product of training
usually does this with unerring promptness for
that one idea is naturally the largest idea
a proposition involves the whole play it
must have a certain magnitude and the play
must be commensurate with it it suggests
action for the last clause reply requires
that a problem be worked out doubt is expressed
the facts are given opposition is encountered
so that's price talking about it and then here
is bernard grobanier in his book playwriting
he says eventually price was able to
formulate his law of plot the proposition
which we are quite willing to agree is the
one significant contribution to the science
of playwriting since aristotle's poetics this
was the judgment of many of his students among
whom were the most successful american
dramatists of their generation it is a
large remark but as we say we do not dispute it
even though price's very name seems unknown to
the public or to the scholars these days if we
ourselves were asked to whom we were indebted
for the basis of our ideas about playwriting we
should have to answer aristotle and price price
really brought something entirely new to
the craft of the dramatist to the craft of
making a story work dramatically for a
presentation to an audience in such a
way that it grips the audience and it's it's a
it's a complete craft in its own and it's just
entirely distinct from storytelling from one point
of view and yet completely married to it because
your dramatizing story it's one of the things that
i an analogy that i recently stumbled onto because
what i'm teaching is seven powerful tools and we
spend two years learning them in this training
program so we'll spend months on each one and you
have to acquire expert facility with each tool
and then you gradually synthesize them together
into one unified expertise and i compare it to
learning how to juggle while you're riding
on a unicycle on a tightrope you have to
learn each of those skills separately and then
synthesize them together into a fluid capability
so it's just a set of skills
that you get better and better at
and you have to keep improving your storytelling
because if your story ideas are weak it
doesn't matter how much craft you have as a
dramatist if your stories lack magnitude then
it's not going to help much and that was a point
echoed by uh ted elliott or terry rozio they wrote
pirates of the caribbean and a whole bunch of
other stuff they said one of the most central
problems we see in scriptwriters trying to succeed
is that their core idea is poor and that's so true
people put all this energy into trying to
turn a weak idea into a stage-worthy script
and it's it's so central to it uh i had
dinner with a showrunner of a top um
network uh tv series and she was saying
that she sees so much bad writing that
will not work for their show and she can't show
it to their to the star because he won't do it
and she said that there's that the writing itself
is often so poor that you have to like decipher it
to get out what they're trying to say and when
you finally get down to the kernel of the idea
it sucks too it's like there's no there
there there's all this stuff built around
something that doesn't work in the first place
so storytelling is hugely important and the craft
of the dramatist is hugely important you can't
succeed as a scriptwriter without both of them
dialed to 11.
how do most non-professional screenwriters
create plot often it's the same as
professional screenwriters but professional
screenwriters can evaluate what they're creating
whereas non-professionals
don't have the ability to
eyeball their material at a professional critique
level so that they'll get excited about an idea
they have it can either be too derivative where
it's been used in way too many movies or tv shows
or stage plays so that most people wouldn't
be interested in it unless the execution of
it is extraordinary which kind of by definition
a non-professional scriptwriter is generally not
capable of doing now some people are just out
of the box geniuses and that's different but
not only is that extremely rare but uh anders
erickson in his book peak said that they
looked everywhere for prodigies who
were out of the box and just could do it
with no training as good as the best
people they said those people do not
exist and they've scoured the earth for them
you hear about them but it's not true so that
for instance say someone has
an innate ability at chess
and maybe they were a prodigy as added as a kid
but didn't push their capabilities and they may
still still perceive themselves as a prodigy but
if you put them up against a genuine chess master
they've never found anybody who without
the proper training could go all the way
uh and i'd never heard that before
i thought there was such a thing as
prodigy anders eriksen calls it the prodigy myth
and they pretty much categorically disproved it
you know and i think that writers who
come out of left field and who never had any
formal training and who write stuff that works in
really unusual ways or they're just brilliant at
it they probably worked their butts off it's not
like they woke up one morning and said i think
i'll be a screenwriter today and spit out a
masterpiece they may be coming at it completely
from left field but they put the work into it
so there's the distinction in that so there's
no savant there's no screenwriting savant where
they're able to to emulate you know how some these
savants can can play a masterpiece without having
known music in terms of reading notes and things
like that i i think there probably are but i think
they also worked their butt off to polish their
craft but you never know anything's quite possible
the real problem is that most scripts suck
seriously and so those are hard numbers
that realistically 98 and some people say it's
99.9 of all scripts submitted are unreadable uh
for a variety of reasons
but if you don't have it all
working together on the page then
the script doesn't work and so
how non-professional writers come up
with ideas is really all across the board
from you know watching some movie and
wanting to basically just copy it to having
like a fever dream that they wake
up from in a cold sweat and like
my god i gotta write that and maybe
it's brilliant and and often they are uh
but almost always they have to have
the craft to execute it properly
you know maybe it's a story their grandfather told
them about what happened to them in world war ii
or whatever and it electrifies them and they
want to turn it into a story it might be just
rolling ideas around in their head and two odd
ideas clank together at one point you'll be like
that's a weird story you know sometimes it's
just colliding two different stories together
uh the story alfred bester tells um he
wrote an amazing book of short stories
called the golden man and one of
them is called fondly fahrenheit
and it's about a robot a really high-end robot in
the future that is the apex of robot invention and
it can literally carve marble like michelangelo
like anything and he hires it out to do jobs
and it makes him a good living but it gets
overheated and something goes wrong and
the robot kills the person it was with
so then he goes on the run with it and
puts it out for lesser jobs because they're
looking for the robot that can carve like
michelangelo so now he has a teaching latin you
know on another planet and it overheats and kills
some so he keeps going on the run and keeps
downgrading what he's hiring the robot for and
bester talked about the creation of that idea
and the original idea was basically that was that
high-end robot malfunctions and he said it just
wasn't enough it was it was not a complex idea
it was too simple and he shelved it and then
a number of years later he came across the
description of a psychological malady in which
one person thinks they're another person where
i genuinely think i'm you and it's like a it's
like a mental illness and i act like i'm you and i
interact with you like i'm you and he said that's
really interesting never heard of that before
and as he was like rolling it around in his
hands he reached up for the other idea and
he did what he called collide them together
to where this robot that was malfunctioning
part of the malfunction is that the robot
thinks it's the master and he said now that
had some juice as a story and he made it into a
fascinating short story called fondly fahrenheit
and it's amazing you know and it's
just that kind of thing and that's
one of the things that we do in the
two-year training program that i'm doing
is that each student has
the the core of the course the 18-month center
of the course we're constantly working on about
six to eight scripts at the same time when
we range from one to the next so we might be
working on an action thriller then the next day
we're on a wacko comedy and the next day it's a
horror story and the next day is like an adventure
story so we're changing gears constantly they're
learning different genres and using the same tools
and techniques across a full spectrum of ideas but
they also have writing assignments exercises to
gain facility with the individual skills learning
games and other things and one of the things
they have to do is to spit out a new story idea
every day and i emphasize like just spit it out
don't get precious with it don't beat yourself up
and if they love the idea they keep it in their
private folder if it's just some dumb idea they
just spit up with they're not attached to it
they put it into the group story bin so that
anybody can work with it we play with it we'll
take one and go let's create a dilemma for that
and if it begins to have legs then that'll become
one of the six to eight scripts that we build
and in the process of them generating a story idea
every day you know i'm saying to them don't worry
if it's dumb don't try to come up with genius
stuff just keep spitting them out because in the
course of this two years you'll develop hundreds
of ideas and you'll get in the habit of spitting
them out and i said you know you may find that
you end up colliding your stupid bank robbery
movie with your crazy time travel story and like
you collide those two together and all of a sudden
you got a fun comedy out of two lame looking
ideas so that's part of what i try to bring
to helping my students acquire
better attack as storytellers and
just better facility creating stories and being
able to recognize a lousy idea from a good one
um oh and by the way uh the term attack as a
storyteller uh came from the writer alfred bester
he um he was a big influence on me as a writer
he wrote two phenomenal novels science fiction
novels in 1954 and 56 one was the stars my
destination the other one is the demolished man
and he's in many ways considered one of
the absolute godfathers of science fiction
he was like the primary influence on
all these people like heinlein and um uh
arthur c clarke all these people like
worshiped him and took off you know built
upon the level of energy that he brought he was
a he originally wrote radio plays for the shadow
that was a you know radio play the shadow knows
and comic book stories and he said that kind of
comic book writing taught him a lot about
attack as a storyteller entertainment value
the outrageousness of great storytelling and just
he said writing for a radio play you got to get
right honored he said start at white heat
and build from there so his his his attack
as a storyteller has influenced me a lot and i
try to um inspire my students to that level of
kind of ferocity like you know it's like
be a wild animal to become a writer to be
domesticated creature to be told what to do and
sit in a corner and salute you know it's like
don't let anybody tell you how to do this
stuff you know it's just it's just the
the whole society teaches people to
conform and sit down and shut up and
not it it doesn't say don't be original but it
defuses in the in the in the sense of diffuse
like make it weaker diff usc but also defuse like
to disarm a bomb to take away the fangs and claws
of people they people are domesticated in
society and we need wild animals you know
we need people that are out there pushing the
borders and seeing things in an entirely new
way and refusing to accept the way things are
and that's so much the job of storytellers is to
lead the way and inspire and show people new
ways to do things um but hang on i'm so sorry
to interrupt you but i like what you're saying but
let me just play the devil's advocate for a second
if you don't know the rules you can't break them
kind of thing so right when when you say to to
push back and don't let someone tell you what
to do what if someone's this free sort of loose
cannon but they're going about story in the wrong
way and then yeah okay there's lots of different
there's really an infinite number of
approaches to any kind of story or anything
you know like even just the way quentin
tarantino with pulp fiction kind of flipped
storytelling in a certain way that we hadn't seen
done in movies much before and did it really well
but he still had really sophisticated structural
technique because he had three different stories
written into a coherent hole so it wasn't a mess
it was a gem so there's so many different ways to
tackle it and what i'm talking about is attack
as a storyteller there's a difference between
wildly explosive creativity as a storyteller
and substantial craft as a dramatist
so there are not so much rules for a dramatist
but a process of thinking habits of
mind like how do you make something work
for for traumatic presentation real actors
acting it out in front of an audience and it
grabs the audience it's all about the audience if
a movie playing to an empty theater has no power
it's just shadows on the wall the power of the
film resides in the response of the audience so
you want like wildly aggressive storytelling
and rigorous technique as a dramatist it's like
it's it's it's an interesting intersection of
something that's organic and messy and something
that's a hard science like medicine is a good
example because medicine taking on like weird
forms of cancer or something that keep evolving
and it's not like they can control it they're
just bringing a rigorous science to grapple with
this organic thing and uh your story idea might be
unlike anything anybody's ever seen and yet you
still have to make it work as a performance medium
so that your craft as a dramatist can help you
wrestle that story into a shape that
makes it performable and gripping
without sterilizing it you're not trying
to defang its energy you're just trying to
make it so that it actually works so that actors
can really act it and it really grabs an audience
so it's it's kind of like inherently contradictory
or it may sound that way at first but really
it's just like make your stories as explosively
creative as you possibly can and it's kind of like
with the old samsonite luggage where you put a
whole bunch of stuff in and then you kneel on it
and just click the latches and then it's in there
if you can get that story into shape so that it's
performable and grabs the audience then it works
you know even if it's something as out there as
being john malkovich where you're like watching
the movie going whoa look at that and you know
it's brilliant and it's fun and it's different
and it works it grabs an audience it's actible
and yet it's coming not even from left field but
like way out there and it's we need that kind of
fresh energy and refusal to knuckle
under to normal story patterns and
even the crafter the dramatist the more craft you
have see it comes down to principle and method
there are certain principles that underlie what
tend to make the tools work and there are certain
methods that embody those principles so
like if the if you have certain principles
that are active there are certain methods that are
created that turn that principle into an implement
and so that the particular tool you're using
may not work exactly for the story you're
trying to tell but it but you can adapt the
story because you're still serving the same
principle there just may be a different
mechanism that can embody that principle
so that you the more craft you have as a dramatist
the more you can adapt because you're still
you're still achieving what you want to
achieve you just find a different way to do it
can you give me an example of a domesticated
writer and i'm not talking about physically
and at home staying home during covid just
just someone that is in a mindset of sort of
the masses and versus this wild unhinged
feral writer well generally those are
the writers of the scripts that
don't work of which there are
millions of them over you know decades
so that even if you look for instance at a
movie that seems very calm on the surface like
ordinary people it won best picture and a bunch
of other oscars i think in 80 or 81 something
around there it's almost just a parlor drama
like people sitting around a living room arguing
but there's so much intensity and so much
ferocity and so much attack it really goes
right for the jugular vein it's not making weak
choices it's making very strong choices and really
making us take a good hard look at the
ugly or dysfunctional parts of ourselves
so that it has a tremendous attack a lot of
magnitude a lot of depth so and that's like
what i'm talking about when i say domesticated
i just mean like making small safe choices
where you know you're reading the script
and you like that you like the pitch and
then you read the script and it's like the pitch
sounded so promising and they just sat back and
you know phoned it in look at like
at this juncture they could have made
so many better choices but they made a
weak one and then it just keeps it's like
you know just a lack of attack
you had talked about attention versus
intention so that has to do with
what um in what anders ericsson in his book peak
and in his whole career talks about as deliberate
practice and that is that say that you're a
you're in training to be an olympic ski racer
and it's a series of individual
skills that each of which has to be
better than anybody in the world if you're
going to win like every move you make so that
your coach is showing you video of like as
a skier i know that you to ski right you're
doing six things at the same time you have
to do all at once and then you're really good
but you have to learn each one in isolation and
then combine them so your coach would be saying
you're leaning a little too forward there and
you're not popping on your when you when you
change you know and they'll and they'll isolate
certain things that they need to improve upon
like you keep you keep not straightening
your knee so they might give them
exercise and have them do it a lot for
instance like one of my friends who was a
played minor league hockey the junior b they
call it his coach would show them how to do it
and then say go do that 50 000 times and then
come back it's that type of thing a deliberate
practice where your ski coach would say you keep
not extending your elbow all the way you gotta
overcome that so every day you'll do that maybe
a thousand times before you do anything else
and instead of going i hate this you you you
do it with full attention and full intention
so that you're really paying attention to it and
you're intending to like i'm gonna master this and
yeah it's boring and everything else but you're
you stay focused and that makes your brain build
the neural network stronger and better whereas if
you're not focused and don't have strong intention
then you don't really get the the cumulative
benefit in the brain structure that seats it as a
deeply habitual so you once you've done that
the whole season when you get into the race then
every time you take a turn you never miss that
elbow lock so that it becomes built in and that's
what erickson called deliberate practice and what
they said was that they found that you don't want
to give the people your training drills but give
them short addictive games they're literally doing
the exact same thing but you make an addictive
game out of it so that they can stay focused on it
better what do you think of writers who don't need
to outline to write a great story well there's so
many different approaches uh i mean the bottom
line is either the story they're writing works
or it doesn't if it doesn't work and they don't
outline then it may be something that they want
to add to their repertoire if it does work then
whatever they've created as their process it
works if the story if people love the story then
whatever they do works it's just one approach to
the process of creating developing
and constructing a story
for me it's a deep habit to do that because
one of the central problems for scriptwriters
is that dramatic writing is an extremely
stripped down literary form it demands complete
economy mostly because it's a performance medium
and the only thing that actually it's
like an iceberg where there's a bunch of
parts of the story that are you know part of
the mechanics of the story but the part that
the audience actually sees on stage or on screen
is just a sequence of events that happens like
the guy walks into the room to get
his valuable thing from out of hiding
and there's somebody watching from the
window or behind the curtain with a knife
and it's just a sequence of events where the
person gets the thing out of hiding then the
other person comes out and tries to take it from
them so it's a highly specific set of incidents
and there isn't room for anything
else in that particular scene
and this is called separating the
necessary from the unnecessary
so that the performance generally it won't
it won't make it to performance if it's
bogged down with the unnecessary because the
script doesn't read well but people will often put
will allow the unnecessary to creep into
the script from all different directions
and the outlining process the way i use
it and the way i train in it is that
you have to get the big building blocks
of your story working first because if the
if the major girders and beams if the big
bones of your story don't work dramatically
then nothing else you add to it is gonna
matter the details don't matter it's like
some writers will have a beautifully written
scene in a script that doesn't work it doesn't
amount to anything it's like having an ornately
finished room and a house that's falling over
you've got gold leaf and oak
and marble and everything else
but the house is literally tipping over so if
you got to get the big structure right and that's
the most basic component of an
outline once you get that working
then you layer in a little more detail so if
you have a sequence of events that constitutes
the spine of your story and those are just the
big building blocks of your story with no detail
and you link those up and
you take a look at it and go
oh that's better than i thought it would be or i
could see how i thought i had a problem in act two
and i can see that clearly now that i've got the
major building blocks and then you improve on that
and then look at it again and go yeah now that
works then you can break that up into acts and
develop a little more detail for act
one so you gradually layer in a little
more detail as it becomes necessary but
layering on only that which is necessary
then you do act two and act three then you take
act one and break it down into sequences there's
two to five sequences in an act and two to five
scenes in a sequence so you break the opening
act down into say three or four sequences you
take the first sequence and you've already got
a chain of events that you've already
figured out from when you figured out the act
and then you expand upon that a little more
it becomes necessary to think it through in
a little more detail so you flesh out your outline
a little bit more and then you do it for the next
sequence and you flesh that out and it's flesh
out not flush out like putting flesh on bones
and you do that for all the sequences
you develop a little more detail so now
you've got an outline that has a reasonable
amount of detail to it and this sequence serves
where is it is tight and dramatic in and
of itself when the audience watched that
sequence there on the edge of their seat it's
compelling that sequence serves its function of
what the act is intended to do the act this
unit serves this unit this is part of this
and contributes toward what the act is trying to
do the act serves the whole because it does it's
part of the mechanism that helps make the whole
story work so it's a unit inside of a unit inside
of a unit so then you take the opening sequence
and you divide it down into scenes and you so
if like this if this is your opening
sequence and there's a chain of events
that constitute that sequence you're going to
say okay this part of it is the opening scene
so there's still that chain of events that you'd
already figured out that are constitute that scene
now you're going to take those events and think
it through in a little more detail you expand
upon it a little more and now you've got final
detail so you have a highly detailed outline and
then you actually write that scene then you think
through the next scene and expand upon the detail
but you're still rigorously excluding the
unnecessary and only layering in that which
is necessary to the sequence of events it's all
about the forward progression of events and that
has to do that's particular to dramatic writing in
a novel you really have a lot more leeway and flow
and but but in something that's being staged
you have to present a clear forward progression
and you and you want that progression to move
well and not veer off into unrelated territory
or you don't want to have a dead spot that's
flat dramatically so you lose the audience
the the basically continuous
coherent compelling dramatic action
is the name of the game and dramatic action is not
car chases and shootouts it's not mere action it's
a state of action that you put the audience in
it's all about getting the audience on the edge
of their seat and keeping them there they're
in a state of action the audience so continuous
coherent compelling dramatic action the word
compelling is actually redundant because
dramatic action is by definition compelling
but it just helps people understand it better
so if it's you always want to have dramatic
action you don't want to ever revert to mere
story you don't want to have parts of your script
go flat dramatically where it's mere information
you want it to always be actible and compelling
so this the scene still is a causes b which
causes c which causes d and so on it moves it has
a good progression of forward action with nothing
it's it's only that which is going to be on
stage or on screen with nothing else it's
you continuously strip away the unnecessary and
the unnecessary kill scripts the unnecessary you
have overwritten dialogue overwritten descriptions
overwritten scenes scenes that shouldn't be there
sequences that shouldn't be there bloated
sequences sometimes you have a whole act
that's unnecessary and what price said was for
that matter your entire script may be unnecessary
which is true way more often than it should
be those 98 of scripts that don't work are
unnecessary they do not work they they're landfill
they they they can't do anything with them
so if you if you are rigorously excluding
the unnecessary from the big bones of the
story to each act to each sequence and each scene
then you building the script section by section
and including only that which is necessary
to the forward action of the story
and the the unnecessary is rigorously excluded
at all times then your working draft consists
of only that which is necessary
every scene is tight and dramatic
the first three scenes each of which is tight and
dramatic make up the opening sequence which is in
and of itself tight and dramatic those four
sequences each of which are titan dramatic
makeup the opening act which in and of itself
is titan dramatic and each of the acts which
are titan dramatic make up the overall story
which is in and of itself tight and dramatic so
the working draft that you end up with is
going to be very much in the ballpark it's
going to be lean and mean now that doesn't mean
it doesn't need work it generally needs a lot
of work but it's not a bloated mess it's
a tight thing that's highly functional and
you can it's basically the whole
premise behind what i teach is that
and this came straight from price that you
can that if you properly engineer your script
before you write it then it will uh save most
of the you'll you can use the same amount of
energy to properly engineer your script before you
write it as you would put into 25 rewrites so it's
better to structure it properly and then write it
and then build from there and storytelling is not
always so hard to do but dramatic dramatizing a
story is very tricky what if a writer says though
these are necessary parts to my story but outside
eyes say no this is unnecessary unnecessary takes
me out of it what is missing from this writer that
they think that their necessary scenes or dialogue
is is actually unnecessary well well first
of all either they're right or they're not um
either the script works and people
want to make it or it doesn't
if a professional evaluates the script
and says i'm not going to make this
then it doesn't work in that instance now
the next professional they meet might say
this is brilliant i love it so it's you know
it's it's flexible in many ways but it's um
it has to do a lot with just the craft
of a dramatist of that writer because
they may perceive that something is
necessary to the telling of the story
when actually it only bogs it down or kills it um
and that happens a lot if they're overly attached
to the story and you know how much craft they have
but it's really
the the showrunner i was talking to she said
that she sees so many scripts that will not
work for their for their show and this is a top
this is one of the top network shows in the world
and she's the showrunner she's a showrunner
on it she says she said two things
what they write either is producible our
star will agree to do it and it will work or
it won't and we're not making it
because it's not what we make um
she said that she can tell if somebody can write
really within the first sentence you know a lot of
people say the first five pages the first page
she says yes first five pages all that but she
said i can tell if they can write or not in the
first sentence and what often happens is if she
says to this writer this script does not work and
the writer says well that's
just your subjective opinion
she's like they say that to me all the time
but they're not right it either works or
it doesn't it's not my subjective opinion
it's my professional expertise that i look
at their script for this show and it does
not work and it's not subjective so there's
there's professional skill sets and then
there's everybody else's opinion about
what they think is professional writing and
really it's either works or it doesn't so
people's attachment to things
that they perceive are necessary
is often mistaken from either an
emotional attachment to the material or
a mistaken sense of craft or you know
just they think they think it helps
make the script work when actually it's
a significant weakness in the material
so they don't know what they don't
know and yeah yeah or they don't
know enough and they stick to their
guns thinking they've got the goods when
like this showrunner would not even
show it to the star of the show
because you know it's like
it has to be this particular thing to go into our
production slate and it's either that or it's not
it's we write a certain type of show and it's and
so the writer telling them look it'll work it's
fresh it's creative it's like that doesn't matter
it's not what we produce so it has to do with
what the professional decision
makers are looking for
and what in their experience ruins the the script
versus the opinion of the writer and this show
runner said it's not like these are like people
that never wrote anything these are rep writers
that are supposed to be professional writers
and they're not even in the ballpark so it was
a huge discrepancy between what people think works
and what the high level decision makers will
let get past their gate to get into production
could it be that they weren't properly told
the exact nature of what they're looking for
i'm just playing the devils out no because the
show's been on for years and it's a it's a known
entity it's like how could you not know what we
produce here um but you know is there
so many reasons why people's writing
don't work from their poor storyteller
they don't have craft as a dramatist
or it's just not right for the entity
they're pitching it to their stuff might be
astonishingly brilliant but it's just not right
for this show so there's it's you can't really
it's not black and white at all there's so
many different angles and approaches and
you know somebody might show up in town tomorrow
with the script the likes of which no one's ever
seen in it makes more money than anything ever
done and wins every award and people are like
what the hell was that we didn't we'd never
seen anything like it we didn't think it would
work and it's brilliant you know you never
anything can go you know but there's also
rules that
work in certain ways for what people are
looking for so there are no rules from
one point of view and there are real rules from
another point of view and all that's real if you
invent an entirely new type of car it still
has to fit on the damn road fit in a garage
even if it runs on goldfish you know it's
like it's still gotta fit certain aspects
of the infrastructure that's out there right
so you can know music you can be roger daltrey
and still follow the right pitch and and cadence
and all that i don't not i don't know much about
music but you can still be unhinged and wild and
now you have tommy and now you have this like
wild sort of creature and this is what you're
talking about with writing that you want to
see someone that's that's got fangs and and
claws and yeah even like with ordinary people
there's not a car chase or a gunfight anywhere
within 10 000 miles of that script but it's
so compelling it's absolutely riveting and
it's shocking it's powerful so it's more about
not blowing more stuff up but going deeper
and not going down the same rut that everybody
else is going down you know it's just don't
settle for less be a dynamic storyteller and
you know don't don't make weak predictable choices
that kind of thing is what i'm talking about
okay you get that at home for free
people go to the movies to see something
fresh and dynamic and world-changing they want
the people that go to the movies are hoping that
your movie will change the way they think for
the rest of their life people want transformation
they're starving for it they open up
their brain and go do something anything
they want a real experience they
want you to knock their socks off
they don't want to see the same warmed
over murder mystery that they can
see coming 30 miles away and know who did it
you know 10 minutes into the movie it's like
i i don't have this two hours to
watch crap i need something powerful
i have a story idea and i'm hoping that we can see
ways to make it more wild and and really sort of
shake things up from what i have okay
i'm trying to shorten it down but my
character the protagonist is a male in his 30s
we'll call him derek and he's always been a techie
he majored in computer science he had a commodore
64. he's always been very heady and flash forward
many years later he gets a very lucrative job at
a fortune 500 company where he's in he's in charge
of the sort of i.t department and their security
and it's a dream job but he's totally bored
there's there's nothing he knows exactly what
his life is and he's completely bored he becomes
a workaholic he doesn't really meet any romantic
partners until one day he goes to a coffee shop
and a very attractive young woman asks for help
with her computer well it turns out unbeknownst to
him he's been targeted by a rival company and they
want to use her to seduce him so that they can get
into the company's mainframe and find out trade
secrets so uh her name is skyler what a perfect
name for for that character and at first when he
realizes he's being used he's upset and then he
realizes he doesn't care anymore and he's willing
because his life really wasn't what he wanted and
he's fallen in love with this woman and he knows
that he's being manipulated and he doesn't care
so um he feels that he can change skyler and
give her a better life and that uh anyway
help me out here how can i make this story better
um give it more sort of a wow factor really
shock people with it well it's
not just mere shock value it's
the thing that i would focus on first is um
what's his name again derek derek um would be a
good strong dilemma for derek being trapped
between two equally unacceptable alternatives
a good example of that would be in the movie
training day where the ethan hawk character
jake is caught in a good strong dilemma
between his his ambition to make it on to
the denzel washington characters under undercover
narcotics squad his ambition he's very ambitious
and his moral compass because he's willing to do
anything to make that squad because he wants to
make detective and get his own division you know
become a high-ranking cop and his ambition is his
weakness so he's overly ambitious and
yet he has a strong moral compass too so
as alonzo drags him deeper and deeper into the
basically the trap that alonso has set for him
his his ambitions are being realized he's
moving forward aggressively and seeing a path
but that also includes corruption and questionable
activities so his moral compass is rebelling
so he can't let go of his ambition nothing will
make him let go of his ambition but he can't
let go of his moral compass either and they're
really equally strong so that's an example of a
good strong dilemma so i would the first thing i
would focus on is a potential dilemma for derek
because there's either a dilemma inherent in the
story idea that you've pitched or there isn't
if it's there then i want to isolate it and
then amplify it to maximize its strength
if it's not there i would
experiment with creating one
and and i'm not trying to force a dilemma onto
it because the story's the most important thing
but a good strong dilemma can amplify
the dramatic power of a story and so
i look at the possibility of creating one without
forcing it or bending the story out of shape
in this one it seems like there is a dilemma
kind of sitting on the surface in other words
i'm not having to go is there one in
there i can see it right there because
it's unacceptable to go along with the
manipulation and generally the dilemma
kicks in somewhere and then around the end of act
one you have to like live with the character for a
while get to know them get to care about the lead
pro the protagonist and for the story to develop
um to the point where somewhere around
the end of act one the protagonist
finds him or herself caught in a dilemma of
magnitude magnitude means significance to an
audience does it hit them where they live does
it grab them is it important like you could have
a dilemma that it's unacceptable to wash the
car it's equally unacceptable to mow the lawn
that is in fact a dilemma but it's not going
to grab an audience it doesn't have magnitude
so so if after a whole act one he's noticing
that he's the subject of a manipulation
and he's like i'm not going to allow myself
to i'm not going to i'm not going to fall for
this i'm not going down that road and
yet we're looking for something that's
equally unacceptable that like it's unacceptable
to let go of this kind of wild card that has
disrupted his
predictable career trajectory
which reminds me of the
story of the musician sting
from the police he was the headmaster of a
girls school in england and he said at one point
he had a a flash where he could see the whole
rest of his life in this really predictable path
and he was like like whoa i am not doing that
like let me out of here and he's like you know
he's like i like music i'm i'm gonna chase that
hard so there's something similar in derek going
i don't like
the trap that she's leading me into but
i do like the trap she's leading me into
and so there is that's why i'm saying i could
see a dilemma sitting on the surface there is
a dilemma inherent in the material
which then now that we have isolated
the the two halves of the dilemma
then the next step that i would do would be to
experiment with amplifying each of those halves
so
if i'm him and one way i do is i i put
myself in derek's shoes so if i'm derek
and not only all my training
in terms of security and i.t and lockdown
and watching the companies back and keeping
predators out and knowing that they're out
there trade secrets and all that kind of stuff
that i'm naturally not only
a guard dog but an attack dog
so like it's unacceptable to let anybody
outsmart me in this stuff because i'm
protecting my master and i'll i'll take a
bullet for them you know it's the attack
dog the secret service all that stuff is kind of
like wired into him and there's a professional
ferocity that like nobody's getting around
me i'm the goalie nobody's scoring on me
and i don't care if i dislocate my arm
and i never play again they're not putting
that puck in that net the more that that
aspect of his personality can be amplified
the more what we're doing is we're we're
jacking up that side of the dilemma
by playing what if with what are the things
that it's like putting a jack under it and
jacking it up a little and at first it'll go
right up and then it'll be like you can still
get one more click out of it and like
what's the most intense you can make it
and and there's a variety of factors that
would inform that and go into that um one
of the things you see often is a past failure um
or he's not going to let it happen again or and
maybe that goes hand in glove with a character
defect on himself or but it's really just like
like my dog will die to keep you from hurting my
kids that kind of thing you are not getting past
that watchdog so amplifying that and then and
and you can see how that it's not that hard
to beef that up to make him a ferocious guard dog
and and and yet because he's also like bored um
dead ended and potentially also has that kind of
revelation that sting had of like oh my god i can
see the whole rest of my life and i'd really
rather shoot myself than go down that path so
there's something that awakens
a rebellious streak in him an adventurous streak
um a kink you know just a fascinating
fascination with this young woman and
it's almost like
an opportunity presents
itself to break out of jail
so
it's kind of a wild streak in this character it's
almost like a tiger that's been raised in a zoo
and is domesticated in a lot of ways get its food
delivered to it all that stuff but some of its
wild instincts arise and it has
a profound hunger to pursue that
and and
the thing to also bear in mind that
as i'm playing with this this is
wildly unformed in my mind so that i'm literally
sitting here with a couple things
in my hand and nothing else
uh so i can see how to amplify that part of
him that is no way you're getting around me
over my dead body but then what i'm also looking
at and i got that that's not going away that's
not so hard we can probably complicate that as the
story progresses or we'll stumble over ways that
are obvious that we haven't noticed yet to make
that even stronger but that's not complicated from
one point of view this is an interesting
puzzle to make this side of the dilemma
more unacceptable more powerful more dynamic
and so all the reasons why he can't let go
of the opportunity that she presents including her
he's just fascinated with her as a possible mate
even if he's already married or maybe
his marriage is dead and who knows
that these are all things to play with
as you play what if with the dilemma but
that part of him
you know for instance like
a crazy what if like what if
like in lethal weapon he goes home and puts a
gun to his mouth and is thinking about suicide
like he's so dead end in this job and hates it
that maybe he's attempted suicide before and
nobody ever knew i don't know maybe he just
plays with the rifle with a handgun at home
that would complicate it gives him more of a flaw
which you tend to want to have and complicates his
approach to the riddle that she presents for
him internally um i think that clearly if he's
great at his job that he has several
different options like he could just
shut her out and walk away and there but then
there's no dilemma there's no story but that's
one of the options once he begins to notice
what she's up to he's like i'm out of here
you know screw you i'm how how why would you
do this to me and you're not my friend and
we're not going down this road and he just
pulls the plug and it's done maybe they got
into a little bit of something and he just covers
it back up or changes something and what they got
didn't amount to anything and he just drops the
firewall on them but what you're suggesting is
quite a bit different than that is that that that
part of him which is starving for some fresh air
can't let go of this opportunity and won't
and even if it ends up
that he ultimately goes over to the dark
side and completely betrays his company
and that gets him out of his trap you know
it's like the bear chewing its leg off to
get out of a leg hold trap that may
be one of his options or that may be
see there's one thing to be
trapped in a good strong dilemma
and that generally kicks in around the end of
act one after we've gotten to know the character
and get the story developed to a point that
dilemma builds an intensity all throughout act two
until around the end of act two it comes to a
critical juncture where it comes to the make
or break point because with dilemma you really
can't choose either way like jake in training day
cannot let go of his ambition and
cannot let go of his moral compass
and the crisis in training day comes when alonso
tries to have him killed by the hillside gang
the latino gang in that house up on the hill
and they're about to blow his brains out in
the bathtub i'm not going to say anything more
about the story because i don't want to spoil it
for people who haven't seen it but that's part
way through it i'm not going to talk about the
ending at all but that crisis forces a decision
in action about the dilemma so that the crisis
demands an immediate decision and action about
the dilemma that the protagonist is still stuck in
and the protagonist once the dilemma comes
to this critical juncture the crisis which
is out around the three-quarters point in the
story the protagonist has to make some kind
of decision and take some kind of action
that breaks the paralysis of the dilemma
so they're now in a fight to the
finish to try to resolve the dilemma
so as i'm wrestling with derek's dilemma and
looking at amplifying it making it more powerful
more riveting to the audience and part of that
is playing crazy what if that's what i'm talking
about like don't settle for the easy choices how
far can you take it how much can you make this
protagonist scream because of this dilemma
the more impossible it is for them the more
the audience comes up on the edge of their seat
because this is our hero in this story and they're
caught in a bad situation and if that dilemma is
universal which you tend to want to do then the
audience is sitting there going i understand this
dilemma because i'm caught in something like this
you know of like a duty versus honor
dilemma or whatever that may not be i
that's not necessarily and that's probably not
a good description of this particular dilemma
but let me let me so let me retract and articulate
his dilemma with that level of simplicity so
duty and honor is definitely there no way they're
getting around me but no way am i letting go of
this whacked out left-handed opportunity that
blindsided me and reawakened my starvation for
adventure and freedom and unpredictability so
really it's a security versus adventure dilemma
which is very universal like no
way am i letting go of my security
but there's no way i'm letting go of my
adventure it's like it sucks being a bank teller
but it sucks trying to make it as a
painter living on peanut butter sandwiches
i can't let go of the security but i
can't let go of my need for adventure
so i i think that's an accurate representation
at first glance of derek's dilemma so
his and i would say that he has a part of
his personality makeup is a deep-seated
need for security and predictability and to be a
good watchdog but there's also the contradictory
part of his personality that's starving for
adventure and fresh air and to get out get
out of that cubicle and start really living life
so not only does skyler and her masters present
an unexpected opportunity but that the deeper
derrick gets in as you progress through act
two and this dilemma gets more and more intense
as things keep ratcheting up that it becomes
more acceptable to let them get around him but
it's also more acceptable more unacceptable to let
go of this dynamic once in a lifetime opportunity
and you know and some of that
would probably have to do with
the nature of the business that business
that he's protecting and the intentions of
the uh predator who's operating skyler
and and you know those are things to
play with for instance is the company
that derek works for maybe the more
derek is exposed to what skyler is talking about
and probably what her boss is telling her to say
maybe derek begins to perceive that the
company he's vigilantly protecting is
actually either a criminal operation or
is doing something morally reprehensible
that makes this side stronger but maybe
what they're going to do with it is
highly questionable or criminal
or whatever so the need to protect
so there's there's story possibilities
that can go in wildly different directions
and you know so much of that has to do with
your intention as a storyteller where you want to
steer the story versus listening to the story like
it basically comes down to what the tools that
you're using as a dramatist suggest in terms
of story possibilities and dramatizing the
material so that it stays active and gripping
to an audience there's like there's like the
demands of the story and the demands of the tools
and you want to really listen to both of them
the tools will suggest certain things the story
will suggest certain things and you want to
really factor them both in like the the um
the technique the techniques of the various
tools involved may suggest that you steer the
story in this direction but your intention as a
storyteller or as the story takes on a life of its
own it may really want to go in this direction and
you want to really be responsive to that the story
is the most important thing the tools are mere
technique that can help you shape the story to
make it work dramatically so it's a given
take between what the story the energy
that the story brings to the table and your
intentions for what the story brings versus
the technique that you bring to the table so
it's kind of like a synthesis of the two and so
you know as i
work with
making the dilemma more and more intense
and riveting and entertaining or compelling
you know it may be a brutal thriller so
it's not like an action comedy at all so
entertainment value is absolutely like
how's this gonna turn out i can't look away
somebody's gonna die here you know it can
be brutally intense and really riveting so
it's not like entertainment value and like haha
funny but it's just like they couldn't pay you to
to leave the theater before it ends um
so that as i build that dilemma toward
the the critical juncture around the end of
act two when that dilemma becomes a crisis
and forces an immediate decision and action
about that dilemma now that it's gone critical
it's like a gun to the head that demands you don't
you don't get to contemplate your dilemma from a
distance anymore going what am i going to do
when it goes critical now it has gone critical
and it's like the gun is to the head and you got
to make a decision right now and take an action
and you're like i can't make a decision
so that's it's it's riveting but as i'm
amplifying the dilemma what i'm looking at is
the point on the horizon that it's all going to
converge toward at the two-thirds point around
the end of act two that what does not what does
what is shaping up as the potential
crisis as i build the dilemma in other
words there could be a whole lot of factors
that go into constituting the crisis which informs
the trajectory of the dilemma because often a
crisis is all the worst possible stuff happening
at the worst possible moment and sometimes the
crisis can involve that you're it's not like all
catastrophic failure all at the same time which is
definitely part of a crisis where everything's
caving in on you at the worst possible moment
but it can also be like that you're right on the
edge of succeeding right as it all goes to hell
you're like i'm an inch away from pulling this off
i had a way out i can do this and it all cascades
into failure so it's not all just it's all going
wrong but part of it it's all going right and this
is the worst possible thing at the worst possible
moment so it's a mixture of the two and it's
so as i build the dilemma the possibilities for
the crisis inform the choices that i'm making
because it's like how can i make
this as gripping as possible
as it gets denser and more
complex and more compelling
and that's where you know like what
i'm talking about about don't make
sedate choices you know it's about entertainment
value about it's about outrageousness and
that doesn't mean just mere wacky stuff
or blowing more things up but it's like
as he wrestles with his dilemma as
things get more and more intense
she i would think is perhaps flowering as a
person in their relationship that she's like
the best thing that ever happened to him but she
may also be the worst thing that's ever happened
to him like she's creating him she's turning him
into a new person but she's also destroying him
so that he can't hang on and he can't let go
and she's like wildly the love of his life
but he still can't jump ship because he's gonna
lose his life maybe in the process of making
his life so it's an aggressive experimentation
with pure storytelling and pure technique and
synthesizing the two where the technique suggests
ramping up the intensity more and more and more
until it's at the like it's like at a point of the
engine is screaming and about to vibrate to pieces
and then everything really goes wrong at
that like at the worst possible moment
a whole other monkey wrench gets thrown into
the thing so it's all like playing with options
um is that helpful yeah i love it i love it
and i'm wondering is there something that's
just dilemma that's just one part of one of the
seven tools but that's where i go first right and
i'm wondering what where could like a meteor come
from another plant and just like just destroy all
expectations because we figured there's probably
going to be two outcomes one of two either he's
able to quote unquote save her and give her
this good life maybe she never had and that's
why she would do such a thing and she needed
the money and she got in with some bad people
or um he's going to he has such a strong moral
compass that he's going to say sorry i can't
do this i not only am i going to ruin my career
but my parents and all my high school friends and
college friends they're never going to see me
the same and i'm going to end up in the papers
and so but then what could be a third thing that
could just come from nowhere that we don't see
because those seem like two likely outcomes well
there's two avenues to explore in that question
one of which has to do with um informal logic
they talk about dilemma as being caught on the
horns of a dilemma two equally unacceptable
alternatives either one will gore you you
can't you can't go either way and they talk about
different ways to resolve a dilemma one is that
you can pick one of the horns or the other you
can pick one of the unacceptable alternatives
and go all the way become a revolutionary with
her destroy the company that he was in or throw
her to the and become a more rigorous guardian
of the he could he could go he could pick one
of those two unacceptable alternatives and go
all the way with it and resolve his dilemma
or by thinking on his feet he could come
up with a radically third alternative
in which he's not choosing either one of the
things that he was trapped in it's like somebody
saying you got to go through that door or you got
to go through that door and by thinking on your
feet you get a chainsaw and cut a third door and
go out that way it's about it by thinking on your
feet you come up with a creative resolution they
call it the third path in the science of dilemma
and so often in a story like this the
protagonist does find a third way out
there's a great example of that in the firm
but let me just say spoiler spoiler alert
and if you don't if you haven't seen
the firm which is a phenomenal movie
hit pause fast forward a little bit because
it's a great example but i don't want to
ruin the movie for people either so
in in the firm tom cruise is in this
high-paying law firm and he finds out
it's actually owned by the mafia and
he gets put in a good strong dilemma by ed
harris this aggressive fbi agent who says
you have to um bring us proof that they
are involved in a criminal enterprise
or we are gonna ruin your life and if he brings
proof then he violates his oath as a lawyer if
he does what the fbi wants he'll be permanently
disbarred because he divulged client privileged
information but if he doesn't do what they're
saying they'll ruin his life it's something like
that i i don't know if i'm saying it exactly
right but it's very much in the ballpark
he finds a creative third way out in that when
he when one of the people he's working with
mentions that they have been systematically
over billing him which they're doing to
everybody and they make a lot of money on
that and it's criminal the guy that he's
the client that he's talking to says what they
don't realize is when they put a stamp on this
that became a federal crime and tom cruise's lies
light up and he's like yes and each single act is
is punishable by you know ten thousand dollar fine
and ten years and each one of those and he goes i
just studied that for the bar exam and he's like
and so what he does he he does not do what the fbi
demands of him but he does not go down with this
criminal law firm either is that he gives the fbi
proof of them systematically
over billing the clients
through the mail each of which is a federal crime
and it wasn't this huge bust that the fbi wanted
but a lot of little busts that have real
teeth and add up to a lot of prison time
but it's a lot of hard work for the fbi but he
gave them by the letter of the law what they
were demanding without violating attorney-client
privilege so he skated between these two equally
unacceptable alternatives by coming up with a
radical third alternative that result that's
that conclusively resolved his dilemma and
made for a satisfying ending to the movie
and so that would be the type of thing that
could work very well in this type of story
so that for instance if for instance there
were some questionable activities that his
the organization that he's guarding is involved
with and the predator wants to get at that it's
kind of like the predator is putting him in an all
or nothing position but he finds a way to maybe
undo some of the questionable activities
that his the organization that he's guarding
is involved with without violating them
without exposing their hard drive it merely
opens up to public scrutiny one thing that
they're doing that they really shouldn't be doing
doesn't and allows the predator to make that
public without hurting the company so he kind
of skates between the trap that he's in and maybe
takes the girl with him as a mate something like
that in which he finds a creative third way out
of the impossible situation that he was stuck in
i like that so he's this that's the door that he's
right okay and by thinking on his feet he came up
with a creative third resolution possibility where
there used to be only two because maybe this this
sort of um this this act of espionage that they
want them to do is because maybe they've compiled
information on their customer base and they really
shouldn't have kept that and not disclosed or
something so what if he somehow i don't know turns
it around so that that that's no longer there or
then the customers are notified every somehow
it's like there's a resolution i don't know
how that would be done should also be something of
magnitude if it's if it's a minor offense then the
audience will go so what who cares so that's where
the magnitude where you it gets up to a level of
like oh that's important i care about that right
but that's just a factor you know that's something
to factor in as you build that half of the dilemma
and it's informed by if the if the predator who's
operating the young woman is showing him things
that are questionable about the organization
he's guarding and he's like yeah you're right they
are you know but you just want it to come above a
certain threshold of questionability right so
don't that's all the particulars of the story
sure so so forge the third path that
sounds like don't take the right don't
take the left try to dig that's just one
possible resolution for this type of story
well it would probably be too predictable don't
you think if if i chose one or the other if i
chose it where somehow he turned these people in
and was able to to still keep his job and then he
marries her and they live happily ever after in
the suburbs and and i mean that's i don't know if
that's really going to work um or if he absconds
with her to the cayman islands and then he's
hiding for the rest of his life that's not going
to work either so right or you know he he escapes
the substantial trap that the predator
laid for him and escapes the trap of his um
rut his career predictable career rut and
potentially some criminality that his or that
the organization he's guarding was involved in
so that he kind of outsmarts his boss
and outsmarts the predator and maybe
runs away with the girl and they hitchhike around
the world i mean like he completely drops out of
the whole arena he was in you know it's just a
part of a creative a a possible creative solution
to the complex trap that he was stuck in and
he becomes a consultant that does like white
hat pen testing types or he may never look at
a computer again they may steal a sailboat and
sail off you know with a hundred thousand
dollars in cash in the hold and that's all
they have but it's he's completely free from
everything there's you know there's so many
ways you can go with the story ending but you
wanted to impact the audience powerfully and
make them
feel different than the way they came into the
theater you know they want to be transformed
even transfigured even like to the point where
they never think the same way again for the rest
of their life it like permanently changes how
their brain is wired that's what people hope for
in a great story that it completely
changes how you see the world forever
most stories don't do that
but the best ones can do that
and it's fun to aspire to what do you
believe is one of the most powerful
plot construction tools currently in the
film industry the one that i teach is
called it's a three-step process called
sequence proposition plot that was invented
by william thompson price but was um sat
undiscovered in his book until i found it
i've taught that to development executives
at all the hollywood studios and they
consistently say it's the most advanced
development tool in the film industry
it's really powerful and it's
unlike anything that's out there
and it's a very sophisticated tool for both
plot construction and story development
it um works with reverse cause and effect and
structuring compelling conflict so that it's
as i was saying before with making the overall
story work first and then making each
act work in each sequence and each scene
it's you it's used for that because
the first the first step sequence is reverse cause
and effect it's the sequence of cause and effect
that constitute the spine of the story the
forward progression of the story so that
using reverse cause and effect you have to
have the mechanics of the story sketched out
first you can't do plot construction until
you have a story reasonably well figured out
um so that with reverse cause and
effect you start at the ending
and work backwards so that you're you're
looking at the ending and you're chaining back
from each effect to its cause so you look
at the ending and say okay well what would
be the immediate cause of that ending and you
find the cause of that and then you say okay
what would be the immediate cause of that
and the cause of that and so on and so that
say it's a it's a um
say it's a story about a uh someone who's
being muscled by a mafia don no someone
who's being muscled by a corrupt cop and the
corrupt cop puts him in a good strong dilemma
and there's no way out and it gets worse and
worse and worse and this character finally
figures a way out and that he makes a deal with
a mafia don to set up this corrupt cop because
the mafia don wants to take out this corrupt cop
so the character sets a trap so that the crooked
cop shows up to like rob him at the at the key
point and the mafiadon swoops in and takes him out
so the ending would be that the guy is
free from the trap he was caught in before
you'd say well what would cause him to be free
it's that the mafia don snatches the crooked
cop and disappears him the cause of that would be
that the crooked cop swoops in to steal the loot
the cause of that is that he sets up the heist the
fake heist to lure the crooked cop in the cause of
that is that he makes the deal with the mafia
dawn so when you play that and that's all right
dense part of the ending but you could
see the cause and effect there where
he makes the deal with the corrupt mafia
don which causes him to be able to set up
the crooked heist which causes him to have the the
loot which causes the crooked cop to swoop in and
take it which causes the mafiodon to be able to
grab the cop and disappear which causes them to
walk out of the trap that he
was in so it's it's a way of of
not only stitching together the the story
components by cause and effect but actually
creating that cause and effect where it may
not exist in other words if you have your story
roughed out and you start doing reverse cause and
effect and you start chaining backwards through
from each effect back to its cause you may get to
a point where there isn't a cause in what you've
figured out so far and that may be a hole in your
plot and the logic of the plot and you say well
what would cause that to happen and you may come
up with a bunch of different possibilities find
the one that works and so then you have the
next cause and then what's the cause of that
so not only are you knitting it together as
you build backwards you're taking what you've
already got a story that's that you've sketched
out but you're now it's like it's like the um
when when you've designed a project and
you know exactly what you want it to do
then you bring in the engineer and say okay
make all the nuts and bolts of this actually
work here's exactly what we want but you got to
do the engineering so we know how heavy the steel
has to be how much concrete to pour and they'll
give you hard numbers of like you need this much
concrete and this much steel so there's one thing
of what you want to achieve there's another of the
engineer comes in and makes it all tells you what
to do to make it all work it's that kind of thing
that as you take the story you've roughed out and
stitch it together engineer it that you actually
create the cause and effect as you build
and the trick to that tool is that you are
asking at each point only what is the cause of
that effect rather than what happens before it
because any number of things can happen before
it but only one thing actually caused it
so that's a way to help separate
the necessary from the unnecessary
it what it does is it frees you from
the profusion of unnecessary detail
the unnecessary kills scripts and
that's one of the things i was saying
i've trained a lot of um creative executives
in at the you know the studios in hollywood
in this tool and when i talk about separating the
necessary from the unnecessary they're all going
yes you know the unnecessary overburdens
everything dialogues overwritten scenes that
shouldn't be there whole acts which they're
bombarded by the unnecessarily constantly
it's one of the major symptoms they see of that
scripts don't work the dialogue doesn't work
the spine of the story doesn't work because
there's too much there's you don't have the
what's necessary and there's too much of the
unnecessary it's a combination of the two so
what merely happens before an
event could be any number of things
the thing that actually causes it is going to
be among those things that happens before it
but you're finding the the key links you're
basically you're you're creating a chain
as you work backwards and when you create the
chain for the overall story the chain of events
and you've rigorously included only that which
is necessary to the forward action of the story
and you've rigorously excluded that which is
unnecessary to the forward progression of events
that constitute the spine of your story then
you've assembled it backwards out of your what the
material you have and when you find holes in your
plot you invent to fill them in so you're not only
structuring it but you're also
developing it you're creating when needed
then when you read it from the bottom up a
causes b which causes c which causes d and so on
that's the spine of your story whereas before
you had a lot of clever elements to a story and
it looked like it worked but you hadn't done
the engineering on it to make sure it really
worked and being able to stand back and look at
your story like it starts here and it moves all
through here it also enables you to get a good
objective look at what you've created so far and
it's not easy to get a good objective look
at something you've been deeply immersed in
for a while because this plot construction
comes after you've done a lot of creation
and development then you have to stitch it all
together into something that actually holds water
so when you stand back and look at it you may go
oh there's the whole spine of the story in simple
terms and you may go well that's much better
than i thought it was going to be or you may go
god that really sucks i thought i had much
more than this but there it is and i gotta
like and you know it's it's it's it can it can
be not working for you in any number of areas
or you may go you know i always thought
there was a some kind of problem in act two
but i couldn't put my finger on it but boom
there i see it right there and you can see
that part of it is distinctly weak and it could
be so much stronger and so you know maybe you fix
it in an afternoon or maybe it's three weeks or
maybe it takes a month maybe you have to read a
couple great books or talk to somebody who really
lived it and then you come back and stitch it all
back together again and then look at it again
and go much better but this one piece is still
weak so you're evaluating developing structuring
and it's all in the process of plot construction
so once you've done the the sequence
that's the sequence of events that
the overall story consists of just the big
picture then so that's sequence out of sequence
proposition plot three-step process so the second
step comes from price's proposition that we were
talking about before using logic to pull all the
story elements together into a coherent whole
like we were talking about how pulp
fiction has three different stories in it
but tarantino did an excellent job of pulling
those all together into a coherent hole
it's not a mess of different stuff it's one thing
that happens to be done in an unusual way but it's
still perfectly crafted from a dramatic point of
view it's it's extremely effective dramatically
and great storytelling has got both so once
you've got this tight chain of events then
you set up a set up a conflict set up a
potential conflict early on in the story
touch off a fight to the finish later in the
story and what price said is instead of doing
a and b therefore c he said central to our job as
a dramatist is to have the audience up on the edge
of their seat at the point when the fight to the
finish has only just started and they don't know
how it's going to turn out so at the point when
the fight to the finish has only just started
the audience comes up on the edge of their
seat like how's this going to turn out
because we've got a powerful proactive protagonist
and we've got a powerful proactive antagonist and
we genuinely don't genuinely don't know who's
going to win how it's going to turn out and
so you set it up you touch it off
you get the audience on the edge
of their seat and you've either
got the audience or you don't
in terms of dramatic power on a scale of 1 to
10 how much are they on the edge of their seat
if it's really powerful then you're going wow yes
this i set it up i touched it off and i really got
the audience if you set it up and you touch it
off and you can see it's still kind of weak or
it's actually quite weak that's the power that's
what the proposition is for so you can propose it
take an objective look at it and then
evaluate it and then revise as needed
if it's only like a 7 out of 10 and you're
like no it needs to be i need a 9 or a 10
in terms of a scale of 1 to 10 for how
powerfully i have the audience on the edge
of their seat at this point when the when what
the whole story is built up to is unresolved
then you amplify different aspects of it to
get the audience that much more on the edge
of their seat so you're you're creating a tight
sequence of cause and effect then looking at the
core conflict in the story because it's really
just two boxers in a ring fighting it out it's
two dogs fighting over a bone only one of them is
going to walk away in the end in fact the oldest
greek drama was only two characters on stage the
introduction of the third character by sophocles
was considered a major innovation in drama so the
ability to see the core of your plot as two main
fighters in a fight to the finish and
only one of them is going to walk away
helps you get right at the core of what makes
your story work dramatically so sequence is
the reverse sequence of cause and effect that
makes it tight this you set it up you touch
it off you get the audience on the edge of their
seat unresolved and if you're doing your job right
the question in their mind about how it's going
to turn out is really powerful then you've got
as much dramatic power as you can bring to
the to how you're dramatizing this story
and then the last step is the answering of the
riddle the completion of the action what how the
fight to the finish shakes out in the back
and forth between protag and his antagonist
and who wins or loses in the end so reverse
cause and effect set up the fight touch it off
get the audience on the edge of their seat and
wrap it up so that's sequence proposition plot
and you do that once to the overall story which
makes it tight and dramatic and well i'll explain
that as i go along then as i said you break the
overall story up into acts like you literally
look at the chain of cause and effect that you did
in reverse and you say okay that right there is
the end of act one that right there is the end of
act two so you've got your axe so you take act one
and now you do sequence proposition plot to
act one so you start at the ending of act
one where it ends up and you've already
got like if you had this chain of events
this part of it is act one so you've got a chain
of events right there that constitute act one
you take that over here and you you so you look
at that chain of events and you're going to start
at the end again and work backwards through it
and think it through in a little more detail
so that you take what you've got and you say okay
so the like the cop comes in and grabs the loot
and the mafia guy grabs him and disappears
him so now you're gonna think that through
in a little more it now becomes necessary
to figure it out in a little more detail
you didn't want much detail when you're doing
the overall story because you want to just see
the main building blocks with nothing else in
there because that's got to work and if you get
swamped by a profusion of unnecessary detail
it can be hard to see the forest for the trees
it can be hard to stand back and go wow
that chain of events is the whole story
you don't want extra you want it stripped
down so you can evaluate it now it becomes
necessary to think it through in a little
more detail it becomes necessary to layer
in a little more detail so you're thinking it
through in a little more detail of like okay so
is it like a bag of money or is it like diamonds
or is it somebody that he was supposed to kidnap
for the crooked cop and how would what would the
rough mechanics of the trap consist of like where
would the mafia guy be and how do they make
it so the cop really puts his foot in the trap
even if there might be clues that he might begin
to suspect or he has good instinct and he's like
something's wrong but he still puts
his foot in the trap so you you
it becomes necessarily necessary
to figure out a little more detail
and then you chain backwards to that to the to
the you you're looking at what you already created
like what was the cause of that is that he does
the actual heist that the crooked cop wants them
to do but there's some falsehoods in it because
it's a setup how does that go down how does he do
it is the crooked cop watching what is he taking
is he swapping it for something that's a key part
of the trap so you're you don't you don't want
much detail because you you wanna it's hard enough
to figure it out and too much detail can just come
up the works um and then you go back to the next
you you look at what the next cause was
and think that through so what you've done
is you may have like six causes that you started
out with that you brought from the overall story
and you've opened it up a bit more so maybe now
there's 12 or something like that so you expand
upon what you already had amplifying in detail
and you've got more then you throw that act into
a two-sided conflict where you set up a potential
fight early on in the act touch off a fight to the
finish later in the act get the audience up on the
edge of their seat about how the conflict in that
act is going to turn out and then a completion
of that action of what's what's the rest of it
so you've done sequence proposition plot so
you've not only constructed the story but you're
literally inventing your story development as well
you're figuring out okay so what would actually
be in that bag that helps make the trap work but
the cop doesn't see the switcheroo or whatever
you're gradually developing those details
without getting into too much detail
but you're you're literally fleshing
it out you're literally inventing
some of it you'll have the details already figured
out some of it you're making up on the spot
and then you're creating conflict in that act
which there generally will be some conflict
but you're really constructing it setting up
a potential fight touching off a fight to the
finish in that act getting the audience out
on the edge of their seats so the act itself
has a high point of suspense at around the two
thirds three chorus point that really gets the
audience up on the edge of their seat and then
complete the action so you've made it tight and
dramatic then you do the same thing for act two
you expand upon the cause and effect thinking
each step through in a little more detail you
amplify whatever conflict is in that act making
sure you have a strong proactive antagonist and
protagonist touch off a fight to the finish get
the audience on the edge of their seat so
act two really gets the audience on the edge
of our seat it's compelling and and it's it you
have a completion of the action within that act
so now act two is tight and dramatic then you do
the same thing for act three then you go back to
act one and break that into sequences there are
two to five sequences in that act and you take
if this is the cause and effect for act one
then you say okay so if this is the bottom
the beginning and this is the end so you say
okay so that much of it's going to be the opening
sequence that much is the next sequence that
much is the next sequence you take this chunk
bring it over here and think it through in a
little more detail you expand upon it and open
it up and you're figuring out the mechanics of
the cause and effect for that sequence and you're
still rigorously excluding the unnecessary and
using only that which is necessary to the forward
progression of the action in that sequence and
then you structure the conflict you set up a fight
touch off a fight get the audience on the edge
of their seat and resolve it within that sequence
so that sequence you've now flushed it out thought
it through made it tight kept the unnecessary out
of it and structured compelling conflicts so that
it gets the audience up on the edge of their seat
two-thirds three-quarters of the way through the
sequence and then complete the action so you do
that for each sequence in the story maybe there's
12 to 15 sequences in the story maybe some more
but that's a lot of work but so is 24 rewrites
so you're engineering your script properly
before you write it so you do it for all
the sequences throughout the whole story
then you go back to the opening sequence and you
look at the cause and effect you've got for that
and you break that into scenes you could say okay
this chunk of it is the opening scene that's the
next scene and so on so then you take that chunk
of the opening scene that's the cause and effect
that you've already figured out and then you at
the scene level you think it through again you go
backwards through it visualizing it in more detail
what would be now you're down to final detail
what would be the mechanics of who actually does
exactly what and you're paraphrasing the dialogue
so now you've got cause and effect for that scene
and then you structure the conflict in that scene
because you never want any part of your story to
go flat dramatically you don't want scenes that
are mere information they're mere narrative you
want the scene itself to be tight and dramatic so
two-thirds three-quarters of the way through
the scene the audience comes up on the edge of
their seat um so you made it tight and
dramatic and then you write that scene
then you do the same thing for the next scene you
you do the reverse cause and effect thinking it
through in more detail dramatizing it and then
you write that scene you go all the way through
writing each scene as you develop and structure
it and then you have a working draft and so
that's the function of sequence proposition
plot as a plot construction tool
it also happens to be very
much a story development tool
the two go hand in hand and glove but it's a
remarkably powerful tool price constructed it
but didn't
complete it he explains it very
clearly but nobody else picked up on it
and you know i read a lot of his students books
and so on and they picked up on proposition and
that really entered the the lexicon of structural
technique for the dramatist not widely but it's
it's certainly known um but none of his students
were talking about sequence proposition plot
his student who you know the two books
that i read for three years that student
student didn't even talk about reverse cause and
effect which price went on and on and on about
so i was like how could they not
be seeing this but it was like
you know finding an old rusty tool out in the
field behind da vinci's old workshop that had
just laid there for hundreds of years and
nobody ever tripped over it and i found it
and it was like this works and i combined it
with what his students did it really wasn't
there price described it but didn't build
it at all and he wasn't even satisfied with
the proposition part of it but his student did a
lot of detective work because he knew that price
had a remarkably powerful tool but it died before
he wrote his next book and explained it so he did
a lot of detective work and pieced together made
the proposition more sophisticated and powerful
and then this other playwriting teacher made
the proposition work even better and i used
all of those and synthesized them together
so this was like an old tool that i found
synthesized together with some of what
his students said and then i added to it
and then worked extensively with it for many years
so it doesn't really exist anywhere and when
i started teaching people kept saying that
they'd never seen anything like what i teach and
that it worked better than anything out there so
partly i didn't expose myself to other dramatic
writing teachers because i didn't want to start
pirating what they were saying i wanted to
just stick with the with the uniqueness of this
and it it works you know it's
a complete working technique
um but it's it really is like nothing people have
ever seen and it really works powerfully and it's
it's very much plot construction uh one of the
things i say that's kind of fun is um i only
teach one thing plot construction and dramatic
principle it's kind of a coan in a certain way
because there are obviously two things but plot
construction comes out of dramatic principle
if you understand dramatic principle the
mc that the underlying principles that make
dramatic structure work then dramatic principle
informs plot construction they're very much the
same thing in the same way that medical theory
informs brain surgery or something like that
they're they're very much different parts of
the same animal um okay so i hope that was clear
absolutely are both books required reading or
is one of them out of print actually neither um
price's book is very dense reading and hard
slogging his students book is really excellent
but i synthesized them to you could definitely
learn from reading them but you can learn
more quickly from studying my book writing
a great movie because it it's synthesized
uh a lot of their tools into a powerful
unit price's book is kind of like
walking through thigh deep mud it's not it's
hard slogging and it's it's a lot of work um so
anybody can go find it it's
it's easy to find but it's
it's brutally hard work and you won't find
what's in my book in those books in a lot of ways
we've been talking a lot about the unnecessary
and how it kills scripts and you said how 98
possibly even 99 point whatever five percent
of scripts are totally unreadable it has to do
with both storytelling and scriptwriting craft
because a great story that is not stage worthy
doesn't work in theater they have
this term they say it's a great story
but it's not stage worthy yes it sounds great
around a campfire but we can't perform it on stage
in a way that will grip an audience so you can
have the best story in the world but if it's not
if it doesn't work dramatically
then it doesn't make a good script
and you can have phenomenal craft as a dramatist
but if your story is poor then it's mere structure
it's just well-structured crap it doesn't do
you any good either so a lot of stories fall
a lot of scripts that don't work fall into those
two broad categories they do that the underlying
story is weak or has been done to death or any
variations on why the story itself doesn't work
or that the structure of the story does not
lend itself to being performed theatrically
as a film tv show or stage or
even dramatic content these days
and the unnecessary
is a big part of that because
the unnecessary crops up everywhere it's the
profusion of unnecessary detail is always
swirling around a story it's it's a lot like in at
nasa they talk about launch weight like a rocket
is engineered to only lift a
certain amount of weight of payload
with the amount of rocket fuel that's on board
and it's a it's an escalating problem where if the
weight of the rocket if if what's being brought
on the rocket gets heavier then you need more
rocket fuel to hoist it which makes the whole
rocket heavier so you need more rocket fuel it
kind of exponentially so they're ruthless
in terms of what gets on that rocket ship
and so because they have to have the launch
weight has to be what they say it has to be
because it's been engineered right down to the
last liter of fuel that's on board so in the
same way that part of your storytelling person
is saying i need this to go in the script two
it may sink it it may just be too much for it
part of what it is is that it has to do with the
forward progression of the story's action and
what the audience is actually seeing there's a
chain of events that constitute a scene or
a sequence or an act or the overall story
and that's what is necessary to make that script
work and if you try to add something in that is
not necessary if you go off on a tangent then
you may you can well lose the audience lose the
audience's um being on the edge of their seat
if it if if you're following a chain of action
each cause creates an expectation in the audience
of like okay so now what's that going to cause and
then the effect of that happens which causes the
next effect and so if you put a cause in motion
and the audience is on the edge of their
seat wanting to know what comes next and
you wander off on a tangent then the audience is
going no where's the thing come on come on and
and it's it can become flat dramatically or dead
dramatically or you just lose the audience and and
if you lose the audience then the dramatic power
of the material fades it's one of the things one
of the reasons why a script doesn't work or
why you know an actual movie or tv show or
stage play doesn't work so it has to do with
the stripped-down nature of dramatic writing
it's a lot like dipping a fish in
acid and pulling out just the bones
that's the bones are what make
the story work and as i was
i've known this before but the the showrunner i
was telling you about said it well she said once
you strip the plot down to its just pure metal
on metal bones that gives you the flexibility
to do something creative with it to to play around
a bit because it's a very tight rigorous structure
so you can you have room to layer in a little
color to let it breathe to let it move it's like
a jazz musician where you know we're going to play
a b sharp d so you know what you're doing but you
can still improvise around it and kind of breathe
life into it you're still following the structure
but you all there's also room to
improvise because it's so stripped down
and that allows it to breathe so it's not
mechanical or anything it's it's alive and so
it's not so much what's unnecessary
it's what's necessary and if
you have if you're a good storyteller and have
great craft as a dramatist then you know what's
necessary to make the story work dramatically
and that's what's important if you're a rocket
scientist and you can't make the damn thing
fly then you don't know what's necessary
so there is really only what's
necessary everything else is unnecessary
some of those unnecessary things can be
little details that add flourish and flavor
and color and breathe life into it but most
of it is distracting extra stuff extra baggage
it's like handing a sprinter a
backpack with 40 pounds of books in it
it it will not work but that's
what people are often trying to do
because they either don't have the craft
to understand that which is necessary
to make the story of their grandmother's escape
from a concentration camp work dramatically
because they're so attached to everything that
happens in the story they want to put everything
in but they're bringing their rock collection
onto the rockets it's about to take off and no
this was my grandmother's rock collection and it
has to come with me to the moon and they're like
not in a trillion years are you getting that pile
of rocks into this launch pad and so that they're
they're ruthless about what gets on that rocket
and not and writers have to be the same thing
that's why they talk about kill your darlings
that kind of thing it's once you understand
the mechanics of what's necessary to make your
story work dramatically then almost everything
else is unnecessary and you're constantly
combating it it reminds me of a an old uh
tom swift's story from when i was a kid he was
an inventor and he invented this device that
expelled water so he could go to the bottom of
the ocean and turn it on and he would make a
bubble the size of this room and he was you know
deep and he was on the bottom working and there
was no water and it literally expelled the water
in the same way that it expels the unnecessary
there is nothing unnecessary
allowed in because you're
rigorously saying what is the cause of that it's
like say that your sister calls you up one morning
wakes you up out of a dead sleep and goes hey
hey i just had this crazy dream that you won
the lottery and i mean it was the most realistic
dream go buy a ticket and you're like no i'm not
sleeping no no go buy a ticket right now you go
buy the ticket and you win you're like whoa so the
cause of you buying that ticket is she said you
have to and now the things that come before you
buying that ticket might be that you get a parking
ticket you buy a coffee you get some cigarettes
all that stuff comes before you buying the ticket
but the cause of you buying your ticket is she
demanded that you do so so you're looking at the
cause of an event rather than what merely happened
before it and the things that merely happen
before it may or may not make it into the script
but only if they see there's the overall
story where the big bones of the action
are set up first and then you figure out the
bones of the action required to make it work
at the act level so you layer in a little bit
more but cause strict cause and effect so nothing
you know so getting that parking ticket may not
be part of the chain of cause and effect that
helped you get to the store and get the
ticket and then at the sequence level
you know maybe that parking ticket is part
of the chain of events that is necessary
or it may not get in at the c scene level you're
inventing a little more but there's things that
never get into the story it's like when you make a
suit there's a pile of cloth left around it on the
floor at the end you've got a suit and there's a
whole bunch of stuff that didn't get into the suit
so it's about that which is necessary and only
that which is necessary and rigorously stripping
out the unnecessary why are extremes necessary
in story it has to do with audience demand
audience demand is a very powerful factor that
the audience themselves are often unaware of
audiences are very demanding you go to the movies
you end up paying you know 100 bucks between the
babysitter and the parking and the 12 for a
popcorn you know it's like you want to go in
there and want something to knock your socks off
you can stay home and watch the paint dry for free
you want whatever it is if it's a romantic
comedy you want to come out of there
feeling really wonderful if it's a horror story
you want to be able to like not go to sleep that
night if it's an action thriller you want to be
tripping on adrenaline when you come out of there
you want that you need it and the times when you
can see audience demand most clearly is when you
go into a movie and it doesn't deliver what you
wanted it to and look at your response afterward
it isn't like uh too bad it's like i needed
that come on you know it's like so it has to do
with the nature of the medium that it's it's
an entertainment medium it's the movies it's a
great tv show it's a riveting play and so
extremes are just one aspect of making a story
work so that it really knocks the audience
for a loop no matter what genre it is
you know it can be a brutal thriller or
a wacko comedy but it still has to work
dramatically and it still has to basically the
final effect of any script is the principal effect
it's like a it's like a magic spell or a
hypnosis where it all comes together in the end
like in a hypnosis i've talked to you for a
while about blah blah blah blah and then when
i snap my fingers you'll be a and boom and all
of a sudden it like crystallizes and you're like
and it's completed the transformation in you
so the final effect the good powerful ending
wraps up and delivers the entire power of the
story into one power like the crack of a whip
where just the last bit of it actually breaks the
sound barrier and that's where the the sound comes
from so a a powerful ending impacts the whole
story extremes are just part of the recipe for
making the story itself great and powerful like we
were exploring streams excuse me we were exploring
extremes in the idea about the i.t guy derek
you know we were looking at his dilemma and just
exploring extremes as a natural part of that how
can we make his dilemma as riveting as possible
so that's naturally part of that is naturally
exploring the extremes so even in a really fun
romantic comedy like music and lyrics
with hugh grant and drew barrymore
it's fun it's moving it's enjoyable you fall
in love with them they're playing with extremes
within the genre and within the tone of this
you don't want to violate the tone of the story
so you're you're not turning a thriller into a
horror movie just to expand into expand forever
it's a bubble you want to not violate the tone
of the story so you're always conscious of
the context of the story and the
extremes that work within the tone
and so on so it's really context sensitive and
it has a lot to do with with the genre but it all
goes back to that the key word in the entertain
in the entertainment industry is outrageousness
so whatever genre you're in
part of what you have to factor in is that
it really is entertainment even if it's a
tragedy it has to be gripping
and compelling and riveting
you know it's about getting the
audience on the edge of their seat
and about you know why do people go to the movies
what do people look for in a great tv series
what do you hope for when you go to
see a play that's supposed to be great
which is a lot about audience demand what happens
when you combine aristotle's dilemma with the
early teachings of a 1900s playwright w t rice
yes he wasn't a playwright he was a script doctor
and a playwriting teacher it was really
a process of synthesizing them together
my playwriting teacher taught me the basics of
aristotle dilemma crisis decision interaction
resolution and then gave me the price the
price book and his student's book to read
so essentially
they one doesn't work without the
other from from one point of view
i've taught this for a long time and
i've thought a lot about how to teach it
and i've tried different things where
i only taught sequence proposition plot
but if you're doing sequence proposition plot to
a script that doesn't have a good strong dilemma
then the underlying material is weak dramatically
so you're merely providing a tight structure to
something that is that's underlying story
is weak dramatically it's kind of like
you've got to have good steel to make a good
sword so even if you have know how to pound
a sword into shape and the steel is poor then
it still doesn't work so it's they're really
i kept thinking well i can just teach
small workshops in different tools but
one is really indispensable to the other
and you know that's true of character
development that your characters have to
be deep and complex and flawed and unpredictable
and familiar and i get a lot of that from the
enneagram which is a personality profiling
system so that in terms of synthesizing
the things that aristotle notice tend to be
common to those dramas that grip an audience
dilemma crisis decision in action and resolution
with the proposition and sequence proposition plot
they are all very much part
of the same process that your
it's kind of like
digging into the ground and finding metal
ore and smelting that ore and refining it
and making that into a quality
metal that you can then build with
so that dilemma
it's all part of dramatizing your story you
got to have a good story idea to begin with
and you tend to want to have your
protagonist trapped in a good strong dilemma
and that dilemma
dramatizes the story it helps make the story
more dramatically effective as you build it
so you're constantly paying attention to
storytelling and the craft of the dramatist
so often each part of the story that you add
to or amplify you're also paying attention to
helping it work dramatically by amplifying the
power of the dilemma making a better crisis
making a more compelling decision
in action a more satisfying
resolution to the dilemma a
deeper more complex character
so that all of it goes into the recipe and you've
got to have quality ingredients and good cooking
skills because poor ingredients a great chef can
have a hard time with really poor ingredients
and the best ingredients can be
lost on someone who can't cook so
that's essentially the nature of
synthesizing aristotle and price
together among many other things
but it also goes back to like what i was
talking about of learning how to juggle
on a unicycle on a tightrope there's different
individual skills and you know the tools and the
underlying principles that make those tools work
and you gradually learn one principle at a time
and one tool at a time and then
synthesize them together into a a
set of professional skills you know much
like a doctor gets in training where
there's a whole lot of training that goes
into their overall professional capacity
and they they often no longer see the
seams between the individual parts
because they've really been synthesized
into one fluid professional capacity
what is the dilemma of magnitude magnitude means
significance substance is it
significant to an audience
you tend to want to have a good
strong dilemma for your protagonist
but the dilemma can be weak it may not
pass what they call the so what test
uh sam cohn the founder of columbia pictures used
to run his development process like this he would
bring his writers into a conference room around a
big long table and he'd put his head down on the
end of the table and go okay what do you got and
the guy would pitch his side he'd be go so what
next blah blah blah so what and and go around the
table and finally somebody be like ah yeah that's
got something that let's work on that so it's that
kind of thing it's like it has to pass the so what
test you've probably seen movies where you're
watching it and it gets going and you're like
wait is that all this is come on you know
it's like or they're telling you a story and
you can tell that they want you to feel x y and z
about your main character but you don't and you're
like i just don't care that's called trying to
dictate an emotional response it's like i'm saying
you have to feel this way about this character
because i say so and you're like i hate this
person you know it's like i don't i'm not invested
in them i do and and that has a lot to do with
like magnitude because if you are focusing on
the specific aspect of a good strong dilemma for
your protagonist it really has to be strong it
has to be significant it has to be of substance
to the audience so that they're really drawn
into it and that goes hand in glove with
universality too because they say that the deeper
you go the more universal your story becomes
so that you could be writing a story about you
know a goat's herd in ethiopia and if you've
got a really deep compelling dilemma then a
banker in tokyo could be like i'm caught in
the same thing and a fisherman in alaska could be
like i'm living that exact same dilemma of like
honor versus duty or so you know what it's like
if the average person in the audience if it hits
the average person in the audience where they
live then they'll connect to it and because if
they don't care about it then you've got nothing
because it's all about the audience whatever your
whatever you're building into your story
has to connect to the audience and get them up
on the edge of their seat and keep them there
so there's a number of different ways in which
you you have to get the audience sympathy for
the protagonist and maintain it if the protagonist
makes a bad choice or whatever then the audience
can be like ah i'm not rooting for that person
anymore i don't like that i'm done like i don't
care anymore so you have to get it and keep it
and so magnitude is just one aspect of that it's
like i was talking about their the tools create
certain distinctions and you want to utilize those
distinctions as clearly as possible because that's
where you get the power of the tools and magnitude
of a dilemma is one of those distinctions what
you don't want to do is muddy those distinctions
every time they become inconvenient
because then you lose the power of the tool
how does a writer know they have a good
strong dilemma well so much of that comes with
experience with the tool and knowing
how to use it fully and properly
you know it it's like you see that in a
doctor where their ability to diagnose
something that's tricky has a lot to do
with their training and their experience
and their training often creates instincts in them
where you know that maybe the professor in medical
school kept saying never forget this you know
you may never see it in your whole career but
always look for it and so even if
the doctor doesn't even remember
that consciously part of their brain is like
going did i check that box and if they actually
do then they're like wait does it hurt when
you sit up in the morning and they're like yeah
what does that have to do my head hurts like no no
no okay we got to get you into surgery right away
you know like they're they don't even
know where that came from but they like
their training is built into their
subconscious at a certain level
so there's a you know it depends on your
experience with the tool and all that
but you know that's a distinction between
a deeply trained writer and one who is
solidifying their craft you know
even as you're solidifying your craft
that's a key thing to look for is the
strength of your protagonist's dilemma
because it's so central it's part
of the foundation of your story
so that you know if you're building a
skyscraper and the foundation has been poured
you know you may get an engineer and
go around and double check to make sure
that the concrete's set up as hard as it was
supposed to so you don't have weak areas in your
foundation or that the substructure beneath the
foundation isn't weak or might collapse in a heavy
rain you really want to make sure that the basic
stuff you're going to build on is really solid
because everything else that comes after
that is impacted if there's a weakness in the
the first principles and the core things
uh one of my friends is a martial
arts teacher and he said that
by being a martial arts teacher for so long
he had to keep focusing on first principles
because that's what he was teaching a lot of times
just the most basic stuff but he said after a
while he realized that it was making him a much
more substantial martial artist because the first
principles are what everything else is built on
and that that solidified his foundation and i
found that that was true too he said they're
first principles for a reason they're the main
underlying components that everything else comes
from so for instance in i taught nonstop for 18
years in these small groups there were six people
maximum and each i was working with each person
on their own script so like if i explained dilemma
then i would go around the room and i might start
with you and say okay what's your story idea
and i you know i explained dilemma i showed how
it worked on godfather tootsie blade runner things
like that and then you tell me your story idea
that you brought and i've never heard it before
so you may have you know some completely wacko
comedy that i'm like wait let me get some coffee
so i can sharpen my brain here i have to like wrap
my brain around it and then look at it i was like
okay is there a dilemma in the story and if there
is can i i can feel one i can see one half of it
very clearly i can feel the other half but i can't
put my finger on it and after a while it's like oh
right it's that oh that's funny yeah yeah
you got a a comedy with a dilemma that's
funny that's what you want like that's clever and
you may be saying i didn't know that was in there
i'm like yeah but that that's my skill
with the tool enabled me to find it
and you're like wow yeah that's i love that i
didn't know that i had that in there i was like
well it it was there you know but i've even i have
substantial expertise in this skill it took me a
bit to kind of feel around in the mud and be like
oh that wow look at that you know so it's like
skill and and familiarity with it but in terms
of a student knowing if they have a good strong
dilemma part of it is experience and part of it
is just rigorous technique trying to use the tool
explicitly and to utilize all its distinctions
very clearly because they have the distinctions
are there for a reason and have great power
and dramatic writing is generally considered
the most elusive of all the literary disciplines
it's tricky it's slippery it's hard to pin down
um a script can work three quarters of the way
through and then fall apart and nobody knows
why it fell apart and nobody can make it work
or a script can have look great on paper have
all the top people all the money in the world and
it goes out and loses a hundred million dollars on
its opening weekend and the same basic story shot
for sixty two thousand dollars in a shoe box and
you know with two actors goes on to win best
picture and you know make a hundred million
dollars and they're like it's the same story
and we had all the top people and everything
and they looked the same on paper but there's
worked and i don't know why theirs worked
and i don't know why ours didn't it it's
slippery and so the ability to use the tools
as rigorously and explicitly as possible
helps you to grab onto this slippery thing
that like keeps spinning under your touch and
it's like i can't even pin it down to use the
tool the more you can use those distinctions
in the tool kind of like dragon talons
where you can grab this slippery marble and make
it actually stop in place and really do like
serious surgery on it and like okay now that may
fix it because i had this wobble and nothing we
did made it work but i was able to really pin
it down to get down to real specifics with it
and all of a sudden like that part of it seems
to work better and yeah it helps the whole thing
so it's part of it is just pure
technique and part of it is just
pure intuition with storytelling skills
and seat of the pants making stuff up and
it's like mud wrestling it's like you're down
in the mud you can't even see half the stuff
and you're like i can't even get these two
to click together you know it's it's not
easy to make a script work and and that's
why i keep saying you've got to have huge
chops as a storyteller and you've got
to have serious craft as a dramatist
and you've got to really be able to synthesize
those two together and the better you get at
that the more your scripts will tend to work it's
about being consistent a number of writers have a
great first script and it's a big hit and they're
the toast of the town and everybody's hiring them
and they can't make their second script work
and they don't know why their first script work
and they don't know why the second one isn't
working and you know being able to be consistent
is is really important and so it's a tricky
business it's not easy and you want to really
have big muscles in every department storytelling
craft as a dramatist character development
all this stuff you gotta really be hitting
on all cylinders to have a consistent career
are there any techniques a writer can employ
to generate a great premise well yeah that
goes back to you know what i was talking
about like attack as a storyteller and
to you know have a sense of adventure or even
depth because you know a sense of adventure makes
it sound like you know you're writing some great
you know action comedy that knocks everybody's
socks off but a sense of adventure can be like
a riveting drama or uh you know a tragedy that no
one will ever forget for the rest of their life or
a completely hair-brained goofy comedy you
know that's like just off the deep end so
it's just thinking big and
going for the roots of what makes people tick and
what transforms people and what kind of situations
are compelling and what has entertainment value
and what's been done to death and what's fresh
so it's really a conglomerate of attack as a
storyteller experience with what tends to work
reading constantly reading great scripts
and pushing the envelope but also
connecting with the average member of the
audience you know one of the things i talk about
in terms of dilemma but it's applicable in many
different arenas is that once you get your story
up and running and you've got something you can
go like okay here it is and it can be dilemma
or anything but one of my fundamental questions
is okay now that i've got this up and running
one of the things i want to do is
in my imagination pick somebody
that lives down the street who might
be a plumber or an orthopedist or a ceo of a
company and like can they connect to this story
because if your average joe doesn't
connect to the story you've created
then it's kind of dead in the
water in a certain way and
you know one of the one of the key things
one of the intermediate steps in terms of
looking at the person that lives across the street
and trying in your own imagination to say would
they do they care about this is looking at the
way in which how do you care about it and and
in what way does it grab you and you may find
well you know actually if this main character
did this and this i would care a whole lot more
actually and and being able to ground yourself
more in the material and the strength of the
material and the universality of the material
that can help you then look at the plumber
down the street who's coming into the movies
on a saturday night with his family and
expecting a fun ride or a riveting adventure
and you know trying to make sure that your average
joe can relate to it and care about it and so on
so that goes into it too i hope that answers
your question it's not an easy question because
it's different for every writer and there are
definitely trip tricks and tips to doing that
but they're all just things that you pick up as
you go along and incorporate into your process
so that you have the storytelling chops to be
thinking adventurously no matter what the genre
and the skill the ability to turn a professional
critical eyeball onto your material and go you
know i had fun creating it and i think
it's great but it's not cutting it yet
so maybe it goes on the shelf or maybe you just
throw it away jeff what is an enneagram and how
does it help a writer create complex characters
the enneagram is a really valuable tool it's a
personality profiling system that is a mix of
ancient wisdom about human nature and cutting edge
psychology i was introduced to it by a friend of
mine who was a top psychiatrist in new york city
and he was a good friend and he loved movies so he
loved to consult on projects that i was working on
so like if i was developing a script
with a client i would often bring him in
uh like one time i brought the actor
john leguizamo to him he was working on
um a murder story and he wanted some in-depth
stuff the kind of stuff that armand could bring
and he met with armand and
i talked to john afterwards
and uh armand had sat him down in front of police
video of a guy who had just murdered his parents
45 minutes beforehand this was real footage and
john said oh my god it messed me up i was like
i couldn't sleep that night and i was like whoa
and i said well was it good research it goes off
top shelf like off the charts crazy
and i worked with armand a lot that way
and at one point he said to me because he was
doing uh character profiles on these at one
point he said to me have you ever checked out the
enneagram it's the best thing out there i'd never
heard of it before and coming from him he was
really brilliant and really at the top of his game
and for him to say it's the best thing out there
i was like whoa it wasn't like oh i think i'll
check it i was like boom i was like right on it
and i studied it intensively for a couple years
and it what it it purports that there's nine basic
personality types and each of them has their own
uh basic fears basic desires motivations
preferences tendencies weaknesses flaws and
there's all these different and not only all
that but each of the nine types has different
aspects like they're either a healthy aspect
an average aspect or an unhealthy aspect and
depending on what shape you're in emotionally
and psychologically you are your life is either
coming together you're you're integrating or
your life is falling apart you're disintegrating
and if you if you are coming together as
a person emotionally and psychologically
then you will tend to exhibit the average
to healthy aspects of the type you are
if you are falling apart as a person then you will
tend to exhibit the average to unhealthy aspects
of that personality type so it is a um and they
say that the average person flickers between all
those all day long where you can have extremely
healthy reactions or actions in certain situations
or extremely unhealthy and you flicker back and
forth all day long like real people in and out
of different emotional states and so on but you
will tend to be what you are in other words if
you tend to be healthy then most of your stuff
will tend to be average to healthy and it is a
so like the nine types are like um they give
them labels but they don't use the labels very
much type 1 they call the reformer type
2 is the helper type 3 is the achiever
type 4 is the individualist type 5 is the
thinker or the they have different names
type 6 is the loyal list type 7 is the enthusiast
type 8 is the leader or the challenger type 9 is
the peacemaker but because each of those labels
has certain connotations with different people
the people who work with it professionally
they'll call you a one or a four or a seven
because it's context free in a
certain way the labels don't bring
their own misunderstandings to people who are less
skilled in the application of the of the technique
so that like a type three the achiever can be
very high performing it'll be like a tony robbins
type where they really work hard to actualize all
their best capabilities tom cruise is a type three
people who can really achieve great things
push themselves to be the best they can be
and can really be extraordinary but in
the unhealthy or in the average aspects
they can be really concerned with how
they appear they're constantly wanting
to look good even if they aren't doing well
emotionally in the unhealthy aspects they can
actively lie to look good even when they're
in really rough shape they're really over
concerned with how they appear and will do
even devious things to maintain that appearance
so that in the extremely unhealthy aspects they
can even be suicidal or murderous to maintain
the illusion of their superiority or achieve
their achievements even if they're not there so
in terms of the
in both the creation of a character and the
development and dimensionalization of a character
these the the the basic human nature which
is built into the study of the enneagram and
the cutting edge psychology
which is built into it inform
what you both find in your character and can
create in your character for instance if i
like for instance going back to your
it guy derek and the young woman skyler
i would one of the things i'd be looking at and
i'd be doing that once i get a dilemma up and
running i'm also looking in the early stages
of developing a dilemma for derek i would
go very quickly to which enneagram type is he
because that's going to inform so much who he
is and how he interacts with his dilemma and what
his basic fears and basic desires and tendencies
and motivations and disabilities and flaws and
blind spots all of that inform not only what
the dilemma is but how he will interact with it
because of his basic fears and drives and all that
so let's see if i'm looking at him might he be a
one or a former it's possible two the helper maybe
three the achiever possible for the individualist
possible because he is an individualist can be
uh intuitive artistic want to sort out their
own emotions before they deal with anything else
uh possibly a type five um a thinker a you
know someone who is perfecting things before
they launch out sherlock holmes was a type 5
wants to have everything like a type 4 wants to
figure out their emotional stuff before they move
ahead a type 5 wants to figure out the mechanics
of a situation and have a lot of knowledge because
their basic fear is that they're not well prepared
so they're protecting themselves so
they want to know everything before they
take a step so they spend too much time
figuring out before they take action
so they can be extremely world-changing
when they're on top of their game
and see things in a completely fresh way but they
can also be paranoid and reclusive and dissociated
from who they really are because they're
desperately trying to figure it all out in
their head before they do their debut um so maybe
he's a five he could be a sixth the loyalist
which is lends itself to the i.t who's the guard
watchdog for this mainframe and the whole company
the type one of the main motivating factors
in a type six is they are constantly hoping
that the next person they latch on to is going
to be the one who can show them how to navigate
life successfully are you the one can you help
me learn how to make my life work which see that
goes with the watchdog for the corporation but
also skyler like are you the one that's going to
show me how to make my life work finally so a six
is a possibility a four is a possibility because
the um a four is inwardly tuned
has a lot of artistic sensitivities
and a lot of inner debate and wants to
make things work at an emotional level uh
i'm not describing it accurately enough
but this is really an overview too but
a four is an interesting possibility
for derek a six is an interesting
possibility a seven the enthusiast is the
busy fun-loving type which could be a very
interesting possibility for uh skyler someone
who's like wildly enthusiastic the life of the
party always busy a healthy seven is a lot of fun
an unhealthy seven can be a drug addict they're a
constant escapist mode a sevens main motivation is
to um in the unhealthy aspect of their fears they
wanna they wanna what's the word kind of dispel
unease they can't sit and deal with emotional
complexity they want to escape from it they
they don't have the the bone that enables them to
sit there and figure it out they're in escape mode
a lot if they're average to unhealthy so they're
always looking for the next thing they're always
planning even if they've spent three months
planning a big cruise with all their friends
they can't enjoy the cruise because they're busy
planning the next thing it's always about their
plans but they can be really fun to be around
and a healthy seven is really fun and a really
healthy happy integrated person so i would think
that she's gonna be pretty unhealthy but they
look dazzlingly fun especially to someone who is
feeling miserable and trapped and caught in a rut
and no way out so it's kind of an interesting
chemical connection where her malfunction
meshes with his malfunction in a
way that she looks like his savior
and he may look like her savior so
they sink on a lot of levels and
they fit each other's compulsive pattern in a
certain way that even though it's an unhealthy
relationship they get a lot of mileage out of
it before the each realizes that wow i'm back
where i started or worse because he's just as
messed up as i am in a completely different way
and we really screwed this thing up you know it's
that kind of thing so in many ways it's a mixture
of what you bring to the picture with your story
and what the enneagram offers as possibilities for
character traits and possibilities for character
you you when you come with your story you have
a certain amount of something already
you're not coming with nothing and
just looking at the enneagram for
instance with the story of derek
you've already got a raw story and we've done some
work with dilemma so you've got him trapped and
then if you find that he seems like a type six
enneagram then the tendencies and basic fears
and all the things that make up a six
influence your story and your story
influences how you use those parts of
the enneagram for instance if you're
looking at the mechanics of a type 6
and it offers some dynamic possibilities for what
derek might be like as he falls apart in a crucial
moment of the story then that could really inform
the story choices that you make and the story
choices that you make can inform what parts of
the enneagram you use or amplify or play with
you know so much of it is an experimental mix
as you're really working with everything to gel
that which you decide to run with one
of the key ways that i use the enneagram
is that if you've got a story idea that's up
and running and you've worked on dilemma then
that's a point as as you begin to
get into dilemma for your protagonist
that's when it's very useful to look at the
enneagram because the the character traits of
the type of your protagonist the personality type
will inform and influence your insight into the
dilemma it can suggest possibilities it can deepen
and dimensionalize the dilemma and the way that i
tackle that is that i'll have that character
in mind like derek and then i'll look at
the one sheet for each of the nine types and
those come from the um enneagram institute.com
website i work with a slightly older one
sheet from when i wrote my book around 2006.
it it fits on one sheet of paper and it has
a lot of information what they have for their
one sheet now is they've expanded upon it
so there's more complexity which is great
i just like going back to the one sheets
that are in my book writing a great movie
because it's short and sweet then once you've
worked with that you'll find the stuff on their
website which opens it up a little more to
be very useful too but what i do is that i
think i put myself in the position of my
character or i think about my character
the lead character and look at the
one sheet for each of the nine types
and i'll sometimes just use my book or i often i
print out the one sheets because i've saved them
and i'll look at a type one thinking
about derek and be like okay silver former
there's some key aspects maybe a
couple on my underline that's a maybe
look at the two go through that three oh
that has more stuff that's interesting
four has some distinct possibilities five and
you know and maybe when i'm looking at a five
well even while i'm thinking about derrick
i may notice that wow that could really be
the the predator who's operating skyler and it
just jumps out at me like wow there's there's
that person so you're just kind of like going
through the nine one sheeps nine one sheets
mostly one character at a time but sometimes
other ones will just jump out at you and
so i found that i think
derek really seems like a six
and kind of like this you know as you're looking
through the one sheet a whole bunch of stuff
starts to light up for you and then once you've
figured out who your main characters are which
type your main characters are even if you have a
couple possibilities like at first you're not sure
you think derek might be a four or a
six and you play with that for a while
and then usually your understanding of
it will crystallize after a while where
perhaps you see how derek reacts in a key moment
and that really resonates with a tendency of
a type six and then you really see yeah i really
think he is a type six not a type four so your gra
your understanding gradually crystallizes at first
it's tentative and you keep the possibilities open
because you're not trying to force any of these
types on your characters you're just trying to
listen to who your characters are
and listen to what the enneagram is
saying as possibilities for them which type they
might be and so on but after a while you will um
your understanding will crystallize and at that
point it's really interesting to go to the book
the wisdom of the enneagram uh which is written
by the same guys from the enneagram institute
and it's a big thick book and there's a 40 page
chapter on each type which takes you much much
deeper than the one sheet did and it
really goes so deep into so many aspects of
that character type that it helps you
dimensionalize them it shows the reasons why these
tendencies are there and why their fear is there
and the way in which they fall apart when
things really go bad for them and the way
in which they can go from being in an extremely
unhealthy reactive state to a healthy proactive
integration where they they can
pull themselves together and become
a healthy aspect of themselves you know and
scripts deal with character arcs so where a
person's flaws and weaknesses and disabilities and
all that are either resolved if there's a creative
resolution and they become a more healthy version
of themselves or they disintegrate and become
you know fall apart completely in in a tragic
resolution but the uh the 40 page chapter is
really a deep and complex journey through the
full mechanics of what makes this person tick
and it really gives you tremendous depth and
dimension and flaws and strengths and hopes
and subconscious attitudes and how they
react in a bad situation and how they can
pull themselves out of a tailspin in
certain types of situations so it really is
very comprehensive and one of the things
that's most interesting about working with
the enneagram is that i've done it hundreds
of times for so many different characters and
for instance when i'm going through the 40 page
chapter for a character that's maybe a 5 maybe
i've already done 15 different characters that
are fives and really studied them in depth and
really know them well but maybe one was like a
serial killer in you know the bombings of ireland
and one is a you know a schizophrenic baker in
argentina and like completely a comedy and so that
the characters come in such completely
different contexts that when i start going
back through something that i've been through
a whole whole bunch of times like the 40 page
chapter on a type 5 it's like i've never seen
it before because it's completely different
because i'm inhabiting this baker now instead of
this bomber and it's literally like i've never
seen this stuff before which is so interesting
because i've been soaking my head in it for
years so it's fresh each time which is
great because that's what you want when
you're developing characters it's not
just a rehash of people you already know
but a completely fresh discovery from a completely
new character and you're not only are you
pulling new material out of
what you've already been through
but your facility with the tool grows and
expands each time so you know you just have
more facility more ability to understand more
complexities and also the ability to just see
it more simply and clearly like oh it's just
that instead of like it's all this stuff so you
you know your your capacity to work with the tool
both clarifies and deepens into more complexity
because sometimes the ability to just see thing
clearly and simply is the aha moment that you've
been working toward maybe for years in terms of
using this tool where you start to understand
the different personality types more clearly even
if you have to work hard to get there each time
but you're a little better at it each time and
yet it's always new that's endlessly fascinating
okay so that's a good tour through the enneagram
jeff can you give us an overview of the 36
dramatic situations the 36 dramatic situations is
really a brainstorming tool it works with elements
that are common in storytelling like madness
disaster ambition those types of things
it was created by an italian playwright
named carlo gotzi in the 1700s
and it was endorsed by gerta and schiller and
on the strength of those endorsements that hung
around for about 150 years until a guy named
george poulty turned it into a book in 1916
and then it picked up some steam again
but it's it's unknown by many people and
i've met a lot of people who said they had the
book but could never make heads or tails out of it
it's it's basically what ghazi said was that all
stories consist of these basic 36 human emotional
conflicts and there are things like ambition
madness conflict with a god the necessity of
sacrificing loved ones and it's very similar
in nature to the periodic table of elements
in chemistry where you know carbon hydrogen all
that stuff so with the periodic table of elements
you could describe anything in this room quite
completely from one point of view like this
table is carbon hydrogen oxygen whatever all
the elements that are in it you can describe
it quite completely from that one point of view
that's only one point of view but that's getting
right at the elements that are in it and in
storytelling it's the same thing where you can say
okay this story has madness conflict with a
god vengeance taken for kindred upon kindred
um and there's different so different
active elements in any given story
which is useful because it helps you when
you're starting out with a story where you can
like for instance let's look at your derek
story idea again so we'd be looking at what
would be let me just get my book here because it's
easy to go down the one sheet oh great for these
so here's a list of the here's a list of the
36 dramatic situations just listed simply
so looking at it in terms of derek's story
so deliverance rescuing or being rescued
crime pursued by vengeance pursuit disaster revolt
daring enterprise the enigma the riddle or the
mystery obtaining madness he may be like losing
his mind as being pressed into this dilemma into
like what do i do here i'm in love with her
she's offering me a life of adventure but i
have to betray my most core values but are those
core values based on something that were real or
was i snookered into guarding criminals i don't
know i'm losing my mind these are all just story
possibilities some of it is like some of what i
was doing were elements that are already active
in the story idea before it's even touched you
want to see what you've got it's like taking
inventory like what are the elements that
are already active in it and there may be
a lot more than you thought there were which is
good um self-sacrifice for an ideal all sacrificed
for a passion the necessity of sacrificing
loved ones is going to have to give her up
rivalry of superior and inferior that's always
a good one because it's so subjective like who's
the superior and who's the inferior and it's
completely point of view sensitive and it can
even flicker back and forth of who has the upper
hand in any given situation uh discovery of the
dishonor of a loved one if he's finding out that
she is you know a criminal obstacles to love is
very active in this story but sit before it's
even touched and enemy loved falling in love
with someone who turns out to be your enemy
or enemy love can be fascination with an enemy
or coming to understand your enemy or falling
in love with your enemy that kind of thing
ambition is very central in this story because
derek is stuck in this rut and he has ambitions
for more but he doesn't know how to get
there and she may awaken ambition in him
or he may have a curious lack of ambition like why
don't i care that i'm stuck in this rut or why do
i not care that she's dragging me down this weird
road so it can be the very absence of one of these
situations like you if you look at a character's
ambition it may be that their ambition is wildly
out of proportion and getting them in trouble or
they could have utterly no ambition which is out
of proportion for a given situation it's curious
i'm like why does this person genuinely not
care which way they go is so it's like it can
be the presence or absence of these things too
that can be suggestive these are really suggestive
elements for brainstorming so you can see that
some of what i'm doing here is as i'm going
down the list and i'm thinking about this story
it's helping with the what if i'm seeing what
is already there before the story was ever even
touched the elements that it showed up with and
what if his ambition to forge a wildly new life
for himself with her is something that explodes
in him like he's realizing how dead his life had
been before because he was just even though
he was dissatisfied with the job in many ways
he was still just nose to the grindstone numb
plotting ahead and he's like how did i ever live
like that for years and years i couldn't go back
to another second of that i'd blow my brains out
it's like yes she's trouble but i can't go back
to nothing i can't go back to an emotional vacuum
anymore i kind of stuffed myself into that to
forge ahead but i don't fit in that room anymore
conflict with a god that's
always interesting because
it doesn't necessarily have to
have any kind of connotation
any kind of religious connotation it conflict
with god suggests a religious connotation
but it's just any time there's something going
up against a bigger power it could be you versus
the neighborhood bully it could be trying to
get you know something done against city hall
so that it's these are very flexible the less
literally you take these the more actual use you
can make make of them so you want to have a poetic
or metaphoric frame of mind as you look at these
you don't want to be stuck with
their actual definitions at all
if you look at one of these things even if it's
not a valid chain of logic that you look at one
of these things and it gives you 10 ideas those 10
ideas are what's important this is just a catalyst
in chemistry a catalyst is something that
you throw into a chemical mix and it creates
a reaction even though the original catalyst
stays the same so even if this triggers
makes you think of something that happened to
you as a kid which makes you think of a weird
possibility for your story which triggers dynamic
possibilities for the ending you've been stuck on
it doesn't matter how this triggered a chain
of thought that got you there their job is
to throw gasoline on the fire and trigger stuff
and that's that's its only function really it's
just a brainstorming tool it's just to expose you
to the elements that are already active in your
story even if you hadn't noticed that already
and to expose you to possibilities that you
wouldn't have thought of in 20 lifetimes things
that you never would never have occurred to you
that all of a sudden are like wow that could
really tweak my third act i've been dying for
something like this you know it's just like it's
it's throwing hand grenades into your story idea
erroneous judgment is very central in this story
look how big it is before you touch anything
because he's like he's looking at
her going am i crazy or is she like
the most exciting thing in the history of mankind
or am i like ready for a freaking straight jacket
and like her too you know it's like i don't
even know which way my head screwed on anymore
and like the things that i'm
contemplating doing with her and
overturning my job and committing treason
and blah blah it's like i don't know whether
to shoot myself or run off with her and have 20
kids like i don't know what i'm thinking anymore
recovery of a lost one is he going to get
his own sense of self back loss of loved ones
is he going to lose her is he losing himself is
he losing his sense of honor so these are like
you want to have a really flexible frame of
mind when you look at them because
you'll get so much more out of them
it's like the wrench doesn't have to fit
the bolt head exactly if it'll turn it
you know even if it kind of fits and it'll
turn it that's all you need you're just trying
to advance your story or to see more deeply
into it because you're penetrating into the
inner elements that constitute your
story this tool is really useful
when you're starting a story from scratch
because say you're riding on a bus and you
hear the two people in front of you talking
and it's a whacked out conversation and you're
kind of listening in because it's so interesting
and one of them says something and you're like
that would make an amazing screenplay holy
crap you rush home and you're like boom oh
i gotta you just go on a mile a minute that's a
great time to go to the 36 dramatic situations
because you're exploding with ideas and if you
look down the list of the 36 you'd be like that's
already in there that's already in there i didn't
know that's in there but boy is that potent and
could that be in there that would really whack
it out in a completely dangerous way or make it
more hilarious or whatever the story is going
it's like god that is pure dynamite and it's
like your head's already exploding with ideas
and you're tossing explosive elements you're
playing mad scientist with explosive elements
and you may hit one of them and you're like
that can't be or could it you'd be like
that's scary that's truly terrifying
i i don't even dare think then but
you can't get away from me you're like
okay well what if i did do that you're like so it
may trigger 100 ideas it's like one of them can
give you a cascade of ideas like you can barely
write them all down you're already cascading
with ideas and this is throwing gasoline on the
fire you're throwing explosive elements into the
mix playing what if and so if that one idea gives
you 10 ideas and each of those gives you 10 ideas
get all that stuff down on paper that's what's
important that thing doesn't mean anything it
just got you thinking so it's a extremely valuable
brainstorming tool in part because you're being
exposed to one complete spectrum of ideas because
where the idea originally came from gazi said
this these 36 dramatic situations are
every element that is in any story anywhere
and a lot of people said that's insane i could
come up with way more and they tried to come
up with a list and they couldn't even get
to 24. they were like actually it's better
than i thought and then schiller and gerta both
said this is amazing and so it just hung around
and it's it's just a tool it's just one complete
spectrum of ideas that you can whip out and use
to trigger ideas for your story and to see
elements in it that you hadn't noticed so that
you're going wow this idea was deeper and more
complex than i thought at first glance there's
more going on there than i noticed at first which
is great because then you've got better material
you've got more to work with if you're doing
a tv series you're like exploding with seasons
and you know cliffhangers and characters these
things can suggest characters they can suggest
resolution they can complicate dilemmas but it's
just one complete spectrum of possible ideas so
it's not the be-all and end-all it's not the only
place to look for story ideas it's just one tool
and not only is it useful when
you're starting out on an idea
but it's useful to take a quick run
through the one sheet every now and
then just like part way through your script
you may go back and look through it and go
a crime pursued by vengeance that's emerging as
a much more substantial aspect to the story and i
hadn't really thought it through yet but so it can
it can just shake things loose or help you solve
things you've been wrestling with or expose you
to possibilities that might never have occurred
to you or help you see that this element is very
active in the story if you hadn't noticed it yet
and then when you get stuck at different parts
of the story where you're really stuck on your
third act or something going back through it
can shake things loose clarify things open up
possibilities help you see things that are in it
that you hadn't noticed before that kind of thing
so it's a it's really an explosive brainstorming
tool and you want to have broad flexibility with
it a real sense of play not feel trapped by any of
it it doesn't dictate anything to you it doesn't
say this has to be in there and even if at the
beginning of the story you were like wow ambition
is right at the nucleus of this story by the
time you've worked on it for a while you may
come back and look at it again and be like
ambition doesn't even matter anymore it's like
i thought that was huge but it's grown and
changed so much so you're not it's it's just
it's just like getting blown in the air by
explosives at certain points in the development
process to shake things loose trigger ideas help
crystallize things clarify things simplify things
complicate things and that's all part and parcel
of the normal storytelling process anyway this
is just some good chemicals to throw in there
that are like fertilizer or clarifying agents or
complicators or clarifiers so you see it in super
clarity all of a sudden like it can take a while
spend time with the story for
quite a while before you get
true clarity with it like um sydney
pollock when they were working on tutsi
spent a long time trying to figure
out what the story is really about
and it wasn't until it finally dawned on him that
becoming a woman made a man out of michael dorsey
that all of a sudden it like crystallizes like
ah now i know in really simple terms that's what
the story is about and he said i went back and
looked at every scene and like how does this scene
work with clarify amplify solidify the idea that
becoming a woman makes a man out of michael dorsey
and he said it helped a lot in terms of
working with the crew working with the actors
his own understanding of it and he said it
doesn't mean the story is going to be good
it just means that i know what it's
about that helps me so much as a director
i think you've said that the word theme has
been misused extensively when it comes to film
and television but i believe you've also said
that beware of the with the simple one-liner
yeah it's a theme is something that is
misunderstood by a percentage of people
uh one of the things that my playwriting teacher
pointed out to me back when i was learning this
stuff and he he explained it and then he said this
is really important make sure you absorb this
and he said the way in which the protagonist
resolves the dilemma expresses the theme of
the story and it's very very clear because
the resolution is where the whole story
comes together and the completion of the
story completes the magic spell on the audience
which crystallizes the mood that they go home in
like in a romantic comedy it's been fun and fresh
but also the romance falling apart and things
getting troubled and then finally coming together
in the end and usually you feel happy and in
love at the end if it's done right and all of
that was skillfully orchestrated by the writer
and the filmmakers and the theme also
comes through that that which is being
said organically by the story comes
together in the ending and so if you look at
the protagonist's act of resolution of the
dilemma and look at the way in which the
protagonist resolves the dilemma that enables you
to put your finger on the theme so for instance
if you uh let's say you know you know what
if with our story about derek that say that
he finds he creates a third way out of the dilemma
in which he's neither trapped by the demands
of his company nor by the demands of the
blackmailer or whatever it ends up being and
neither one is a good way out and by thinking
on his feet and maybe working with skyler he
comes up with a creative way to skate through
this horrible trap that he was in and so if you
look at not you look at what he does but you look
at the way in which he does it it's about like
thinking creatively and realizing what he really
needs in life where he was always denying
his own needs and lying to himself and like
that he's finally brutally honest with himself
and is genuinely in love with her even though
she has betrayed him but she's also been a victim
and she's changed and he's grown and he's able to
synthesize a new life for himself in the process
of figuring out how to get out of the trap that
all of that is what the story is about
thematically it's about creating a new life
for yourself and finding a way out of hell and
powering out of a skid and you could see that that
creative type of resolution of taking command
of his life and powering out of a bad situation
is what the story is about thematically and what's
interesting about being able to articulate the
theme that's emerging organically from a story
is that you often only start with a sense of it
like in looking at that type of
possible resolution for derek i can
see it and sort of talk around it and describe
it in a bunch of different ways like i just did
like i just said it about 10 different ways but
my my ability to articulate it crisply and cleanly
is not there yet because it you
have to live with it for a while and
look at what the audience leaves with they
leave with a sense of that theme in their
gut in their soul and if you stop them on the
way out and ask them to articulate the theme
they probably couldn't they just
have it at a gut level it's in them
so it has a lot to do you want to be able to dwell
with a partially formed understanding of something
as a crucial step in synthesizing your
understanding people are very uncomfortable
with partial solutions they always want to go no
i need to have the whole thing in my in a nutshell
so they don't like partial understanding it kind
of freaks people out but as a creative writer you
need to get comfortable with that because so
often you're feeling your way through things
where you're beginning to understand it at a gut
level but you have no capacity whatsoever at first
for articulating it and maybe you finally just got
a handle on your theme and your writing partner
comes in the room and you go like i got it i got
it your writing partner is like so what is it
what is it spit it out and you're like i can't
yet i got it leave me alone get out of my face
let me just sit here with it because i got
it and people are feeling creatures that
long before speech people just felt animals do
that were feeling creatures and so the ability to
look at the res look at the the protagonist's
resolution and look at the way in which he
or she resolves the dilemma will put you
right on the theme that's actively emerging
from organically in your story and it may be
diametrically opposed to what you thought the
theme of your story was going to be starting
with a sense of theme can often be troublesome
because you can end up being preachy and trying
to dictate that to the viewers or the readers
as opposed to that which organically emerges
as the story takes on a life of its own
the characters take on a life of their own and
you have to be able to if you're still stuck
saying that the theme is what you set out to have
it be you may be the one that's missing the boat
the view if the viewers see that movie they'll
get it organically and carry it away in their gut
and think about it for a while
if it's deep and compelling
and it may affect how they interact with people
for the rest of their lives like they never yell
at their kids again for the rest of their life or
something like that because something was awakened
in them even if they can't explain it maybe maybe
later they'll be able to but the important thing
is that you changed them through a complete
the complete action of a compelling story
so being able to have a good strong sense of
theme that's really emerging from your story
is critical because you as
the writer need to be able to
be in touch with the theme that
is coming through the story
if you're still stuck on what you thought it
was going to be then you're missing the boat
you're missing the chance to work with the
real theme reinforce it utilize it and so
your story will tend to be weaker or you're out
of touch with what your story is actually doing
you know it's like you raise your kid and my kid's
going to be a doctor my kid's going to be a doctor
and you still see that because you're intent
on seeing that but if you look at the reality
of what your kid is doing you'd be like he's
a jazz musician holy crap i thought he was a
medical school but no he is genuinely a jazz
musician so it's about what you want to see
versus what's really there
and theme is huge because
you want to be able to connect to the theme
that's emerging from your story reasonably
early in the process um you could see that
with the derek's story i went right to dilemma
and i was all and once i'm working with dilemma
a bit i'm looking ahead to crisis because that
gives shape and and focus to the theme the theme
is going to converge at the point of crisis and
force it is decision in action when there's like
maybe 10 or 15 minutes left in the movie and then
the protagonist actively resolves the dilemma once
and for all that's the ending of the story and
then the way in which the protagonist resolves
the dilemma enables you to put your finger on the
theme that's actively emerging through that story
and you'll start early in the development process
of your story but you've already got a tentative
statement or a tentative handle on your theme
you want to that's why i said
beware of the clever one-liner
because if experts in creativity say there's often
10 right answers to a question and if you seize on
one of those and say that's the answer then you
miss out on all the other layers of complexity
so again it comes back to people's discomfort
with a partially formed understanding
they it freaks them out to dwell in that area
where they sort of understand it but not really
but that's the bread and butter of a writer where
you're gradually morphing through evolving ideas
and once you can
feel the theme and live with it and look at all
the aspects of your thought story through the
lens of your gradually evolving understanding
of the theme it will inform the whole story
because the theme really is what the story is
about it's that they call the governing or a
governing idea or the underlying philosophy of
the story or that which is being said by the story
and it may be again it may be the opposite of what
you set out to say or what you even want it to say
but that's what's really coming across to
the audience and that's price said that
the theme well let me read you this quote from him
yeah so so this is price writing in 1908 about
playwriting so i was talking about plays but it's
it's exactly the same stuff the highest form of
play involves the philosophy of life so that if
the so that if the theme is not worth considering
there is usually little substance in a play
with a theme your play will be about
something theme does not stand alone
no principle does mere theme will never
make a play but it is a definite something
it furnishes a spiritual atmosphere and the
philosophy of the play it gives the clue to the
actual shaping of the play the tone depends
upon it it is the largest unit of the play
that's a very interesting statement that
the theme is the largest unit of the play
that's really interesting for instance the
biggest organ in your body is your skin
so it's it's that kind of thing the theme
is is not infects the whole story
that's not the right word but it's
it's spread throughout the whole story it
determines the shape and the tone of the story
and all that stuff so it's the ability
to come to grips with it is important and
gradually as you spend time living with it
your ability to articulate it will be enhanced
until it kind of crystallizes and then you're like
oh yeah now i can explain it quite clearly like
sydney pollock could say the way that becoming
a woman made a man out of michael dorsey like
there's a really crisp clear statement of what
that story is about thematically and it and it
helped him so much and it gave a shape and
a tone and helped him communicate with the
actors and all that stuff so it's a
uh very powerful aspect of the story
and the basics of it is you don't want
to rush it let yourself dwell with a
partially formed understanding of it and
it will gradually gel and then crystallize
but not if you rush it jeff for this interview
you've you've touched on so many different parts
of your courses in your book i'm wondering
if you can talk a little bit more about
what you will be incorporating into your what is
your two year program that you've launched okay
and and how that benefits writers yeah uh it's
the same tools that i've always been teaching but
what i used to do was 30 hour intensive weekends
or 30 hours like every tuesday night three hours
for 10 weeks and the tools are complex and
sophisticated so that fire hose teaching
is not at all the best way to instill deep
know-how with these tools and i wanted to really
find a much better way to teach so that i
spent a couple years just thinking about how to
teach it differently and to teach bigger
groups because it was always limited to
six because i felt like i had to really get
each person using the tool on their own script
so they could get experience using the tools
properly and see their stories respond to it
the word of mouth for those classes was
through the roof because people loved the tools
they got a chance to really use them
and their scripts improved quite a lot
but i felt like they couldn't go home and use
these tools with expertise you know it's like
somebody teaching you how to build a rocket and
get it to the moon you have to really study every
part of it and break it down and integrate it
and synthesize it into a comprehensive expertise
so you know i really studied
the science of learning and
the science of training people and expertise and
and the science of cognitive apprenticeship and
found a way to teach a large group of people over
a much longer amount of time i found that i could
turn people into seasoned versatile dramatists
who could make scripts work of any genre
and could tackle any medium and so you know
it's a it's a high-intensity training program
and it's still the hands-on intensive process that
i've always done but i've opened it up quite a bit
so the core of the program the one thing that i'm
actively doing as i teach is an 18-month period
where all we're doing is constantly working on
maybe six to eight different scripts of different
genres and at different stages of development so
that one day we'll be working on an action comedy
the next day it might be a thriller and so
on so we're continually changing gears and
moving from script to script so you get you get
experience with different genres and and even
different mediums one will be for a screenplay
one will be a tv series one will be a stage play
and one of them we're just starting
out one of them is mostly done
and everybody's working as a group and they're
still doing writing assignments and exercises and
learning games and there's like group problem
solving like if we're stuck at the end of
you know a thriller trying to figure out how the
murder actually goes down maybe we'll spend a
whole week on it and are completely stumped
and so we have group problem solving where
i'll have everybody coming up with ideas that
you know like their assignment would be to go
home and come up with 20 different ways to pull
off this murder and then look at your 20 ideas
and sort the best ones to the top and then put
those best ones into the group and then everybody
works together to sort those best ones to the
top so we may end up with 20 or 30 phenomenal
ideas the best of the best and we all look
at those and go wow these are really great
this one could really solve our problem this
one solves it and opens up an interesting stuff
that would make us complicate the story
earlier on it like opens up a whole lot
more this one is so good we should set it over
here and make a whole script out of it on its own
but it makes the students do the work
themselves it's not about them sitting
back and watching me do this stuff it's
about me making them as proactive as possible
so that the more expertise they acquire the more
they're integral integral to the process so that
if we come to like a horror film that's
partly developed there might be a team of
advanced students who are actively working on
that every day and we say like oh so how's it
going in there say well we solved this now we're
stuck here we use this tool and so and so came up
with this phenomenal idea and it's it's fun and
we're doing great but we're stuck here and then
everybody is participate on that as a group and
there might be a teaching moment where i end up
giving a whole lecture on this particular aspect
of one tool and that teaching lecture becomes
part of the permanent teaching library that
anybody can go to at any time and i'm basically
turning these students into rough and tumble
experts who can really tackle anything
sometimes i feel like i'm training them to
be like rodeo clowns or something because i
don't know if you know this but rodeo clowns are
high skilled gymnasts they're like really really
technically proficient and really i mean they
go up against a sixteen hundred pound bull
to distract it to rescue the rider and like
they like grab a fence and leap and they're like
unbelievably skilled and rough and ready and can
tackle anything and and so it's like that kind of
versatility and flexibility and attack and high
degree of skill in multiple highly technical tools
and you can throw them into a comedy or a horror
film or a thriller and they're like i got this
and that's what i'm that's what
they're all building toward
and so really i only do one thing and that's this
open workshop where we're constantly building
scripts and that's all we're doing and that's
how i train people and there's definitely
teaching moments here and there as they come
up but it's about learn by doing it's a real
apprenticeship we're really building real scripts
in real time and the challenge that i had when i
when i when i was wrestling with how do i teach
larger groups and teach differently the question
that finally freed me up was okay so if i could
wave a magic wand and teach any way i wanted to
what would i do instead of stuck in all the limits
and how do i get out of this it was like no no no
if i just could wave a magic wand and do
anything no limits no anything i was like
okay well i'd take two years and really train
the crap out of them like really train them
and then okay so if it's a two-year program how do
i make it so the big question was how do i make it
so people can join in because that you know it's
like you hear about the program and i want to
join them and i'm sorry it's another 14 months
before the next one starts that doesn't work
so i was like okay so how can it be a continuously
ongoing open workshop where we're just building
scripts all the time how do i make it so anybody
can join in at any time so i said okay so
if there was a three-month training program
that's basically a pre-recorded video program
and it's the building of a complete
script in those three months
it's kind of like a a flight simulator where you
take this three-month video program and i start
on day one with a one sentence idea for a thriller
and we're by the end of the day one we've already
got an idea up and running we're looking at her
dilemma already and then and they have exercises
and learning games and assignments but not too
much but it's it's intensive and then day two
we're building more and it's all me on video
talking to them but i'm giving them assignments
and trying to make them as proactive as possible
and they're copying down the use of the tools
and learning how to think and seeing and and
participating in the creation of this story
and even though they can't participate in the
actual creation of it because that three-month
class may have been recorded two years ago i still
give them professional assignments say okay so
she's stuck in this room and this person is
watching her but she's got to get a message
to so and so or she's dead i don't know how to
do that your assignment is go home and come up
with 20 different ways she might do that and i'll
show up the next day with my solution for that
and i can't interact with what they
did because this was recorded years ago
but they had to really wrestle with the
problem and really think it through so
i'm trying to make them as proactive and
as involved in the process as possible
and as we use all the tools and they end up hand
copying all the sequence proposition plot we do as
we construct it and then once we've done it we've
done it for the overall story they've hand copied
that done a free check they've hand copied that
just a few pages each day due to all the sequences
and then we come to the first scene and we
structure that scene and they actually write
that scene and then the next day we structure
the next scene and they write that scene
we go all the way through and they each person
writes their own version of this thriller
and when that's when they've got their own version
that graduates them into the 18-month program
so it's a way to give them enough exposure to the
process see all the tools in action they're not
tasked with trying to learn the tools their main
job is to observe everything it's to get oriented
so they see the whole process and then when i'm
training them intensively in the 36 dramatic
situations and they're like i hate this why is
he having us do this over and over again they're
not going i hate this they're going oh i see how
immensely valuable it is because we did it there
and so not only are they oriented and they've seen
the whole thing so they understand how each part
functions as part of the whole but when they come
out of that three-month video recording program
they can jump into the 18-month program and
we may be spending the whole week figuring
out the ending of a romantic comedy and they can
jump right in they know they understand sequence
proposition plot dilemma all these things it's
not foreign to them so they can jump right in
and participate so that means in this ongoing
18-month thing they can join in at any time
and then as they acquire more and more expertise
and i give more and more responsibility to them
and challenge them more and they're always have
to be able to articulate their thinking process
as they wrestle with the tools so
that the experts toward the end of
the 18 months i can say to them as they're
wrestling with the ending of a ghost story
i'd say okay so articulate what you're
thinking and they'd be like well okay so
we have a good strong dilemma but we're still
struggling with the crisis we have this this
and this for the crisis and i'd say have you
thought of that and they'd be like good point
they'd throw they're not thrown or i'd say
like wait you did that wrong and they're like
well so what i'd be like this this and they go oh
of course like they're they're almost there you
know they're like and everybody's learning from
that and and the more and more expertise them
the more they don't need me my instructional
voice is internalized into their own process
they can emulate my thinking process they can
emulate they have the metacognitive skills to
evaluate their own professional process so
they can be like i'm doing the technique
properly but i shouldn't even be focusing on
that because here's the main question so to be
able to challenge their own professional skills
and kick themselves out of bed and reverse their
own trajectory and all that is important
then in order to graduate from the program
they do the last three months which is to build
a script on their own still in this open workshop
and we've been throwing ideas that people don't
so much care about into the group's story band
and even working on them so they pick an idea from
the group's story bin develop it build it in an
open workshop that's open to everybody and it's
like a teaching hospital where i'll come by with
the whole group and go how's it going where are
you at and they'd be like well i solved this oh
that's great that was a hard hump to get over and
they like tell me about it and this is the tool
i'm using now here's where i'm stuck i may have
some insight or i might say wow that's brilliant
and the other students may have questions and
they're articulating their thought process and
when they complete that script they can graduate
and they take that script with them it's theirs
or they could if they want more they can
do another one like that or they can also
stay in the group and they may like collaborating
with the people they've been through with and they
can be in private sessions where they still
have this as like their writer's group and a
coffee shop and they have people who can read
their drafts and brainstorm with them so that
that kind of interactive capability with people
who know the same tools is there for graduates
and it's it's not open to the other people because
they want to be really working their scripts now
but they may like the the community so that's an
option too so it's really the 18-month there's
three months to get into it it's kind of like
if you're going to go up and work on the space
station nasa will put you through a training and
then you can go up on the space station you're
not going to get people killed and you can operate
in zero g and you know know how to function in an
emergency and all that stuff and then the last
three months you do it all on your own which
completes this the synthesis of all your skills
and your abilities and your you know your your
functionality to where you feel like you can go
off and do your own thing or stick around and
keep working with you know the same community
in a private format that's not open to the
whole group but you can still interact
with people so that's the basics of it
it's been fun to create it's been really
challenging and just trying to figure out
all the things and integrate all the new
learning techniques that i've found and
keep challenging myself and it's been still is
i'm still in the middle of creating it and it's
it's fascinating again it was i got
burnt out on teaching the same thing
non-stop for 18 years it was really good to get a
break and now it's really fun to come back into it